Tim,
Tim Dum,
Dum,
[inaudible]
Duncan Trussell ties a falcon on his coat.
Her idea,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast has begun.
Bitches.
We are brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com oh and,
and I didn't really annunciate the o correctly.
Did you notice that?
I'll just skip over it,
but I just had a,
I had met,
I got some slobber my tongue miscalculated.
That's a frustrating thing when you tongue miscalculates and word comes out
wrong.
Yeah,
I feel like a fucking loser.
Especially when it happens on stage.
Oh,
that will throw you off on it one.
Yeah,
we can.
And it can happen in the middle of an awesome punchline.
And even though the punchline is still makes sense,
people like,
Eh,
nope.
Cool nature.
This business on it.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
we all took Alpha and right before the show raise gentlemen and I,
people say,
hey,
Joe Rogan,
do you really take all this shit?
Yes I do.
I would not sell it if I did not take it.
It's really hard to keep it in your butt too.
Yeah.
You can't put these in your butt because they're made out of gelatin and then
you have gelatin coming out of your butt for real.
They just found out that your body absorbs it the way your mouth does.
If you broke the powder down,
if like you took the capsules out,
what is these?
They make vegetarian capsules too,
which I don't understand.
I guess it's like you can make like a gelatin and veggie vegetarian stuff.
What did,
what did we mean?
What the fuck are those?
The outside of the pill made of?
Isn't that like a concern with some people?
Like they don't like swallowing pills.
They didn't want to eat all that gelatin.
Totally,
but gelatin is good for you.
Like Jello is awesome for you,
isn't it?
The vegans don't want to eat it because it comes from hoofs.
Oh,
those weak ass bitches.
Yeah,
that's the pro.
Not all of them.
Rich Roll.
I love you.
I love you Mac.
Danza you guys are my favorite vegans of all time.
Oh,
and by the way,
Mac Danzig has his own podcast now and uh,
it was,
uh,
first guest,
was,
uh,
I believe gray Maynard.
Um,
he might've sent me an email that I need to go and review here,
but I would like to promote it because Mac is a very cool guy and a very
intelligent and interesting guy.
And um,
I think that his podcast would be bad ass.
Luke Rockhold,
who's another interesting cat.
So it's Luke Rockhold,
a gray Maynard end Mac Dansik together for a podcast.
Uh,
so I don't know where you would get that,
but if you go to Mac,
Dan's six Twitter,
which is Mac Danzig MMA,
go and check it out.
And a very,
very cool guy.
Mac Dancer and one of the nicest vegans you'll ever want to meet.
And he can eat our hemp force protein powder.
Do you know why?
Cause it's totally Vegan.
Super fucking healthy for you on it makes the best tasting protein powder on
earth.
The Shit is
expensive.
And here's one of the big reasons why it's expensive.
We can't grow hemp in the United States of America,
Ladies and gentlemen,
we can grow it in Canada and buy it and then bring it to America.
But you cannot grow it in America magazines because we are really retarded and
2012 the year 2012 but when I say retarded,
by the way,
I'm not going to stop saying that.
You fucking over-sensitive twats you annoying pains in the asses.
Don't say retarded.
I can't believe you use the word retarded.
Retarded is not a medical designation or distinction.
It's not.
It means retard or slow or like too slow to catch up unknowingly slow,
retarded,
get it.
You know what it means?
Doesn't mean someone has down syndrome.
Goddammit.
It doesn't mean someone who has some sort of a chromosome disease.
It means you're fucking retarded.
And if hamp is illegal in 2012 that's all it is.
It's fucking retarded.
It makes no sense whatsoever.
Not even a little bit to 100% non-psychoactive.
You will not tap test positive for it.
If you have a drug test coming up,
they'll tell you you have to not eat poppy seed bagels.
You know why?
Cause he'll test positive for heroin.
Crazy.
But you will not test positive for marijuana if you eat all the,
the hemp force protein powder in the world.
We can only buy 50 pounds of this shit a day.
Yeah,
it's amazingly stupid.
And by the way,
the federal government stepped in because Vermont passed a law allowing them to
grow hemp farmers for jobs,
for farmers folks.
And a real legitimate product.
I mean,
it's not a backdoor to get marijuana legalized.
That has absolutely nothing to do with it.
This is just focused on hemp as a commodity.
Hemp makes you see superior paper.
Hamp make superior cloth.
It's much more durable than cotton cloth.
Hemp has essential fatty acids.
You can eat it.
It's high in protein.
You can fuel fucking cars with it.
In fact,
you can make hemp boards to build houses and you can make hemp parts to build
fucking cars and it's far stronger than steel and it's lighter in weight,
you know?
Yet Corvettes are made out of fiberglass.
Well,
Lotus made an a hemp car.
Henry Ford's first car that he ever made,
the panels were made out of hemp fiber.
Ms Sounds ridiculous.
It sounds like I it at some point in time I must be making this up.
Yeah.
There's gotta be some negative side of this while this shit shit is legal,
but there's not,
there's no negative side of it.
None.
Zero,
Zilch.
It's healthy.
It's a,
it's an excellent plant and we're being robbed.
We're literally being robbed by pharmaceutical companies,
by chemical companies,
by anybody that would want to keep enough fellow,
but anybody that would want to keep hemp illegal,
it's fucking maddening and frustrating,
but you could buy it.
You still buy it.
You go to go to on and.com you,
you buy our hemp force protein powder.
It's the shit.
It's got Maka in it and raw cocoa and it's fucking
delicious.
Maka give you a rush.
Take Maka gives me like three cups of coffee.
Kind of weird buzz.
We'll give you a bit of a hard on as well.
Does.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be very stimulating for the system.
Get your whole screen can and fat than like drinking a smoothie and then looking
down.
You've got a hard cock head.
If you guys heard of hot rod 5,000 no.
It's a natural supplement that you can take that's extracted from aunts and a
bunch of fucking other natural shit that just gives you these crazy boners whoa.
Like,
like,
like ti was telling me about it.
It was just amazing.
He said,
I took it by mistake.
I can't see t with a crazy,
crazy boner.
I could see him with like a,
like a whiny boner.
No,
dude.
Have you not followed him on Instagram?
It's all shots of his six pack belly and fucking,
he's like,
God.
Like he's like a cheetah,
a male Cheetah.
What is he doing?
Just try and get some,
get some blizzards.
Dude,
he's pimping it out there.
He's rocking his 40 [inaudible].
He's got a Bruce Lee.
Bruce Lee.
Weird.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well when you oh yeah.
Well you don't eat much.
Get skinny.
Yeah.
That just should do action that they should do action movies.
Packs it like the next text.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
totally,
totally.
That he could definitely be the kind of like a bedraggled detective that's like
kind of disillusioned with a force but ends up like die hard in space.
Yes.
You guys are obviously higher than I am.
There's no other explanation for this.
[inaudible] dot com we also carry a kettle bells,
the finest kettlebells you can get,
a highest quality.
They will last you a lifetime.
Uh,
there we sell them,
we sell everything we sell is cheap as we possibly could sell it.
We just started selling Blendtec blenders.
We literally sell them for $200 less than the manufactured suggested retail
price.
I'm more,
it's actually more than $200 less.
We try to sell things is the best shit as cheaply as possible.
This BLENDTEC blender is fucking bad ass.
Got a BLENDTEC.
They're,
they're amazing.
And when you get it,
if you buy it from Onnit,
you also get a free container of a hemp force protein powder with your order.
The BLENDTEC is,
I started using it to make that bulletproof coffee too,
but cause that Vitamix,
you got to like push it,
push it down with it yet it's too crude and stupid.
Yeah.
BLENDTEC is better.
Uh,
I use the Vitamix for awhile.
It's just more mechanical.
A kid's show,
it only has two speeds and you shove the thing in there,
but Blendtec does it all for you.
And it,
it's,
it pulses it where it like slows the,
uh,
the,
the cutters down so that the stuff settles and then it kicks it back up again.
Like they have it down to a science and a,
I use it for a,
my Kale shakes.
I use it to make bulletproof coffee and a,
so we're selling that stuff as well,
a rope around and make a smoothie with my Blendtec.
It's scares me like,
it's like so powerful.
It feels like it's gonna blow up.
Like I feel like,
I don't know if I should put my hand over the top or like get
away from it because it seems,
it's just,
it's really,
it's dangerous.
When they did blended,
we showed her on the podcast before we ever got involved with blend tech.
We actually uh,
were just randomly talking about blenders on the podcast,
like to make smoothies with,
we had no like business affiliation with them and we started pulling up these
videos with Blendtec where they are blending up iPhones.
Yeah.
We take an iPhone attorney the fuck a dust and be like whoa,
that's metal.
There's like there's metal in that in glass.
It just destroys it.
I'll just,
you can I make this sounds like we're doing it.
I'm not,
this isn't a commercial,
I'm not sponsored by BLENDTEC in any way.
I eat blend tech made smoothies but you can pour like sometimes I'll go to the
farmer's market and just throw in like random vegetables.
You just throw everything in,
blend it and it heats it up to cause the,
the,
I don't know.
I don't know what that is going so fast.
Yeah.
I do vodka orange in ice cube.
Yeah,
that works too.
You could totally use it to make alcohol shit.
Yeah.
It's,
it's the ref for making mistakes.
It's a budget.
An awesome blades.
You could use it to get rid of a body.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
I think you need to pick up a corpse.
Need pigs for that.
Did you hear about the guy in Oregon a couple of weeks ago fell on his pigs.
Felons,
pigs.
They just chewed his ass up.
That's the next thing I'm hunting.
I want to hunt some wild pigs.
They have like a real problem in Texas,
man.
I could get into that.
You in the pig hunting?
Fuck yeah.
Okay.
That's what we're doing.
We're going pig hunting.
Not really intense part is butchering it.
That's when it's going to get intense on a.com.
O.
N.
I.
T.
We also have shroom tech sport,
which I should have taken with me on my crazy hunting Montana because I could
have used it going up those hills.
Shroom tech sport is fucking fantastic.
If you're involved in anything that involves endurance like I,
I love it for Jujitsu.
Do it before I had my kettle bell workouts or anything like that.
Shroom tech is a,
it's an incredible supplement made from the quarter sups mushroom and it's just
shown to aid in your body's optimization with the oxygen.
It's really interesting.
It gives you like a real legitimate endurance boost.
Um,
and uh,
it's also great for people that go into high altitude places.
It helps you to,
uh,
adapt to the altitude quicker.
You if you go from like sea level up to like 8,500,
9,000 feet.
So sometimes people can get sick and uh,
we've had many people tell us that they've,
they took shroom tech for this very reason and then it really helped them and
minimize their,
uh,
their,
their problems and shifting to the higher altitude a shroom tech.
We also have,
um,
new mood,
which is a five HTP and l trip to fan supplement and it's called new mood cause
it literally enhances your mood.
It makes,
it's all the building blocks for Serotonin,
including El trip to fan,
which converts to five HTP and five HTP converts to Serotonin.
So there's a bit of a time released a factor in there as well.
And it's a really excellent supplement.
And a one that I suggest.
I mean I think everybody can be a little happier.
Everybody could use a little bit more serotonin in your life and make it a nicer
fucking person.
So new mood is again,
one of my favorite supplements.
If you use the codename Brogan,
you'll save 10% of any and all supplements from Onnit.
The other stuff like the the and the Kettlebells,
we saw that as cheap as we possibly can and we will continue to sell you the
best shit as cheap as possible.
And when you order pills,
if you ordering any of the vitamins or supplements that your first 30 days or
first 30 pills rather,
I fucked that up every time.
It's like you say 30 and you have to say days.
It's like for whatever reason we're locked into this idea.
First 30 pills.
When you order one of these fucking things right in front of my hand,
try it.
You don't like it?
There's a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
We're just trying to sell you the best nutritional supplements possible and all
shit that I use.
No one's trying to rip you off.
And if you use the code name Rogan again,
you'll get 10% off.
Go to [inaudible] DOT TV and pick yourself up some groovy psychedelic cat shirts
designed and created by our very own Brian red band.
And uh,
all the proceeds go to him and the desk squad podcast network,
which now features Kevin Pereira.
Yes,
our friend Kevin from attack of the show has a new Badass podcast on the desk
squat network called pointless and he is a bad motherfucker.
I love that you listen to that last one.
I did not listen,
but he's one of my favorite guests ever that we have on this podcast and create
such,
such a smart dude and cool and righteous and just,
he's just legit all around.
He says,
I really love that dude and I'm so happy that he's a,
a part of the desk squad podcast network.
Um,
my new teachers@higher-primate.com are in.
So,
uh,
go and check that out.
We have three new designs,
including two with Duncan Trussell from the Tabernacle,
that poster from the Tabernacle that Mike Maxwell did,
and the poster from,
um,
Chicago.
Um,
the,
the Chicago theater with also with Duncan and Joey Diaz.
And the Tabernacle was the one where I filmed my last special and that,
yeah,
that is coming out.
I swear to God,
we just waiting for the web's a lot of CGI.
I bet this is just about the website.
The website is being redesigned and that shit takes a long time.
I hired an actual real professional to do it this time.
Let's see if it turns out to be a disaster.
Anyway,
hired Dad's primate.com Duncan Trussell is here.
Strap yourself in you dirty,
dirty bitches.
We're fixing to get the party started.
Real good experience.
Try My day job.
[inaudible]
San Francisco,
Brian Red Band.
Greg Fitzsimmons and I are at the Nob Hill Masonic order to the Masonic
Auditorium and a,
I've gotten more than one email from really dumb people think that because I am
playing at the Masonic Auditorium,
it just proves that I am a new world order shill.
Yep.
Reptile.
Did you follow her?
Any light bringer?
Lord Lucifer,
I am a part of the masonic,
uh,
what do they call themselves?
Brotherhood leg.
They're a fraternity,
fraternity.
I'm part of the,
the Masonic fraternity and uh,
I'm in with the new world order because I'm planning at the Nob Hill Masonic
Hall.
Sorry.
You know what a Mason told me once,
he said that what it's all about is that math or geometry is the first language
of the universe.
It's like the first language of God.
And so like they're super into sacred geometry.
Like that's a big thing.
And like the whole things based on building the Temple of Solomon,
which was where you,
how's the Ark of the covenant?
You know,
it's all symbolic of course.
But the new temple of Solomon that they're trying to build according to the
conspiracy theorists is society like this is it.
Like society is the New Temple of Solomon and part of that was getting the
United States revolution to happen cause they help fund that and also fucking
DC,
the street layout of DC is all masonic symbols and that goddamn obelisks popping
up out of the middle of fucking DC.
That weird thing.
And it's all over our fucking money.
So Yeah Joe,
we are worried about you.
There is something going on behind the scenes,
right.
I mean it's,
it's clear if you look at the design of Washington DC and folks,
you should really should look this up online cause it's not something that,
it's irrefutable.
Yeah.
The Grid,
the grid,
the way they lined up the streets,
the way they put the buildings and everything.
I mean it literally is masonic symbol.
It is.
And it's all of our fucking money too.
Yeah.
What's up with that fucking all seeing I have of the preamble.
Can I on top of a pyramid that makes sense.
The United States and its long love affair with Egypt.
Think how the Egyptians help form our constitution.
Yeah.
Right.
No one thinks about that shit.
That's what's so fun about the occult,
you know,
cause the word or call itself means hidden.
But it's like hidden in plain view cause this shit's in front of everybody.
Like all the people who deny conspiracy theories and stuff in their wallet or
Fucking rectangles covered in Egyptian occult symbology that they don't even
think about.
For folks who don't know the,
what the symbols are in Washington DC,
the way it's set up is one of them is uh,
uh,
Lucifer,
uptight upside down Pentagram.
Sure.
I mean,
so the horns stick up in the air.
I mean there's,
that's,
that's there,
I mean they did design this,
they really did design the streets like this.
And the other one is,
um,
like that masonic symbol that looks like a measuring device.
Yeah,
yeah.
That,
that means a lot.
But yeah,
that's why,
that's why they liked that because they're trying,
what they're trying to do is to sort of articulate the primary,
um,
the,
the very first way that the universe form,
which is through geometry or through like a cascade of like specific physical
laws that are based on math.
It's super fucking cool,
man.
I mean,
that's what masons are.
Well,
that's what a Mason told me at a wedding.
I don't know.
He's drunk too.
Yeah.
I met a drunk mason at a,
at an oak show,
at the laugh factory in Houston,
uh,
showing me his mason ids and shit.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is being a mason?
What do you,
what do you guys do?
It's like,
Oh man,
it's just secret society,
you know,
hung out together.
Yeah.
He was,
wasn't got together.
We had to rituals where you come out of a fucking coffin.
I know that happens.
Okay.
But how much power do you really think they have wheeled try to use?
Is there really anything to what they're doing or is like being a mason?
Just fun.
Uh,
I began an elk's lodge.
I've heard there's bunches,
there's many different levels of the thing.
And I imagine that a lot of Masons,
uh,
are probably in politics.
And when you're,
when you're in a fraternity,
in you're in politics,
you're probably gonna pay deference to other people in your fraternity when it
comes to working together to make laws happened or whatever you're up to.
So I I a lot of people say it's a waning population that,
that the masons are kind of like dying out because fewer young people are
signing up because they don't recruit.
So to become a mason you have to ask a mason so you have to go to the masonic
lodge and be like I want to become a Freemason.
And then they do like background checks on you and so that become masons?
Yes.
Let's do it.
I've,
I think it'd be a blast.
What do you think is good about being a mason?
I think ceremony is,
people are going nuts right now in front of them.
Peter,
it's fucking shoes.
He's a fucking new world order shields.
Where's the Alex Jones hotline number?
I need to call him.
Right.
Joe Rogan has publicly admitted on his show.
He is amazing.
He has Duncan Trussell on it talks about how wonderful it is to be a main fan
and spreading propaganda from this information about Mason's being about
geometry.
They're about control or about taking your soul.
Why you see gentlemen going to stand for,
well
man,
I don't know.
You know,
who knows.
I think uh,
ceremony is a,
c is something that is missing from a lot of people's wives in our culture
because it's so goddamn weird.
And I'm like,
someone wants to get married.
Yeah,
yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
Someone wants to get man,
well that is that definitely,
that is definitely a ceremony.
But like,
you know,
there's a lot of other ceremonies to that aren't quite so,
uh,
based on like on stupid shit.
But I mean there,
but they are like,
there's their,
their psychedelic man.
And like I read this somewhere,
I don't remember who said it,
but it was uh,
an interesting point,
which is that a rock show is a ceremony and this sense that you're going to this
too to watch people on stage crew like doing like songs which are a kind of
chant that everyone already knows and you're taking psychedelics to go enjoy
this thick.
So it's like that,
you know,
that Youngian idea that like there's just certain basic things that tend to
repeat through all different cultures.
And the way it's repeated in our culture is more through,
I'm going to go see a rock show and dress in a certain way and take a
psychedelic and trip out and have a kind of transcendent experience that comes
through the music.
But it used to be like,
there's more formal versions of that idea,
which is like you take a psychedelic and then you do a series of like
intonations or whatever the fuck it is depending on what religion or cult urine.
And that creates a kind of transcendent connective experience,
which I think is fucking awesome.
And it's fun to just watch regardless of whether or not you believe in what that
red religion or ritual is trying to invoke.
It's just cool to watch that form of dance and movement happen.
It's a funny way of putting it because most people would never think of ceremony
that way and I think what would a lot of these people that are freaking out
about masons and all this,
I think people are nervous about any group that that moves in secrecy.
You know like that was a one of the Kennedy's speeches.
Remember that say societies,
he should not be tolerated.
Remember that?
I don't remember what the,
the actual speech was,
but I wonder what that was in reference to bronze CDFI.
She could pull it up.
Pull it up.
It's Kennedy on secret society.
Laser in the middle of your forehead is so crazy.
Look,
yeah,
I know.
It keeps popping.
It's like right on here.
Not The fact that I'm wearing sunglasses and dressing at NASA out.
What a weight pull up candidate.
What?
Where are we bombing?
I sent you my son tripping out Kennedy on secret societies.
Pull up the video.
Kennedy on secret societies,
you know,
I think,
um,
we learned a lot from those early guys.
Early presence for they learned how to shut them up.
You know,
when Eisenhower was talking about the military industrial complex and giving
that speech the,
I'll never fucking forget that speech,
that that is not that I saw when I would happen,
but it,
I guess the very word secrecy is repugnant in a free and open society and we are
as a people inherently and historically opposed to secret societies,
the secret oaths and a secret proceedings.
We decided long ago that the dangers of excessive and unwarranted concealment of
pertinent facts far outweighed the dangers which are cited to justify it.
Even today,
there is little value in opposing the threat of a closed society by imitating
its arbitrary restrictions.
Even today,
there is little value in ensuring the survival of our nation if our traditions
do not survive with it.
And there is very grave danger that an announced need for increased security
will be seized upon by those anxious to expand its meaning to the very limits of
official censorship and concealment.
That I do not intend to permit to the extent that it's in my control and no
official of my administration where there is rank is high or low civilian or
military shoot.
Interpret my words here tonight as an excuse to censor the news to stifle
dissent,
to cover up our mistakes or to withhold from the press and the public the facts
they deserve to know what we are opposed around the world by a monolithic and
ruthless conspiracy that relies primarily on covet means for expanding its
sphere of influence on infiltration instead of invasion on severity one instead
of elections on intimidation instead of free choice on guerrillas by night
instead of armies by day.
It is a system which has conscripted vast human and material resources into the
building of a tightly knit,
highly efficient machine that combines military,
diplomatic intelligence,
economic,
scientific and political operations.
Its preparations are concealed,
not published.
It's mistakes are buried,
not headlined.
Its dissenters are silenced,
not praised.
No expenditure is questioned.
No rumor is printed.
No secret is revealed.
No president should fear public scrutiny of his program.
For from that scrutiny comes understanding.
And from that understanding comes support or opposition and both are necessary.
I am not asking your newspapers to support an administration,
but I am asking your help in the tremendous task of informing and alerting the
American people for I have complete confidence
[inaudible]
and the response and dedication of our citizens whenever they are fully
informed.
That's a scary fucking at all.
No,
I'm sorry.
Well,
it's chilling.
Scary about that video is that that guy got murdered.
Yeah.
You got to start wearing a fucking helmet.
If you're going to give a speech like that,
what do you think it's like to actually be there
president?
Do you think that you just immediately meet with bankers and finance ears and
they just establish your agenda like right off the bat?
I mean,
it's pretty obvious that he was warning us about some shit that he used in
countering,
you know,
he was the president.
Yeah.
I think
he was sort of experiencing the IX,
the growth of the CIA.
The CIA was starting to,
uh,
turn into this monster that they couldn't control anymore.
I was starting to expand and stretch out and doing that thing that big
organizations do or they try to keep themselves alive by making up shit.
You know that thing where like they're not necessary anymore,
but it doesn't matter.
Just want the power.
Yeah.
That's what people don't understand.
When you start talking about the government started talking about like,
well what's the government?
You know the government is going to be either Mitt Romney or Barack Obama.
Yeah.
Not so much.
There's a whole secret government.
There's a,
there's a whole CIA thing.
It doesn't have to report to anybody could basically do whatever the fuck it
wants,
changes laws.
That's the real government now and that's just like exactly what our founding
fathers were trying to avoid.
Having one of those
great book called acid dreams that I'm reading,
which is about the CIA and how they were the ones who got LSD and they're the
ones who this CIA basically started the psychedelic revolution in the 60s,
or was part of the start of that because they started doing LSD tests on college
kids.
And so they're the ones who got it into the,
into our society.
And it's a fascinating read because LSD,
whenever it gets into whatever group it gets into and it's such a potent
chemical,
it starts transforming the group and changing the way the group thing.
So a lot of people in the CIA or were taking LSD because that was part of the
deal is they would dose their agents to get them ready for the eventuality of
potentially being,
uh,
given a truth serum or some kind of psychedelic brew.
So you would go to work as an agent and all of a sudden just start fucking
tripping cause they dosed your drink.
You know,
who was a part of the Harvard LSD experiments to Ted Kaczynski,
right.
So Unabomber,
yeah,
they fraud that dude's brain.
Yeah,
exactly.
That dude's brain and made him see the eventual takeover by,
by technology.
He was terrified of the takeover of technology,
of the human race,
and he really literally felt like he was protecting the human race by murdering
people who were innovators.
Imagine having a hardcore psychedelic experience on Sandoz LSD straight from
fucking Albert [inaudible],
Albert Hofmann sneaker just juiced out of his socks into vials and send to the
CIA.
Imagine having that trip.
But you're a CIA agent.
You work in one of the most covert organizations on earth with people who are
trained to kill and poison and take cyanide pills if they have to.
Death bills,
imagined being tripping and that kind of environment.
That's fucking insane,
man.
That would be the worst trip.
And I,
in this book,
it talks about one of these agents like ended up committing suicide because his
mind just couldn't handle what it was like to be part of that web of insanity.
And the Senate did trials with the CIA for these ridiculous experiments that
they were doing.
Uh,
some of which involved.
Did I tell you about the sleeping room?
Did I tell you about the no.
So they would go into,
they were doing this shit,
uh,
mental health facilities and insane asylums.
Um,
and what they would do is they would take people and they would drug them.
They would put them into an induced coma for a month straight.
It was called the sleeping room.
They put you in an induced coma for a month straight and have headphones on and
try to reprogram who you are as a person to wipe your fucking identity or
replace your identity with some new thing.
Because if you can do that,
then you create this like wonderful fucking operative.
Like you get to just make a person,
you know,
get rid of all that Pesky fucking,
the memories of their parents and whatever the fuck they think they are or
whoever the,
and they can do this chemically.
Well,
no,
no.
This shit got shut down because it's so unethical.
But where it gets weird,
and we talked about this on the phone is a,
in Guantanamo Bay,
they've been giving people six times the appropriate dose of Laurium,
which is this medication that you give people from malaria that has negative
psychoactive effects.
Specifically.
It gives people amnesia.
My friend just fucking got an Amnio,
wrote a book on getting Amnesia and India,
uh,
euro,
he's wrote a book called the answer to the riddle as me.
His name's David Mclain,
but he went to India,
took Laurium,
uh,
which is a drug that is illegal in some countries.
It's a drug that came from a partnership between what's that big pharmaceutical
company,
Hoffman de la Roche or whatever the fuck the name is.
And um,
uh,
the military made this shit to fight Larry and Larry Holmes sits in your liver,
but sometimes it crosses the blood brain barrier and when that happens,
it mouth fucks your brain.
It just,
the mouth fucks your brain until you start having these shitty fucking dreams.
And then if,
if it really goes wrong,
you can have what happened to my friend,
which is complete and absolute amnesia.
No memory of who you are.
No memory of where you are,
how you got there,
who your family is,
anything.
No memory of anything.
This happened to him in a fucking train station in India where he said that they
were having,
like they would have English,
which he could understand on the TVs and then it would switch to like Hindi.
It would switch to other languages and he thought when it switched to other
languages,
he was hallucinating and the English was like warping and turning into something
else.
He didn't even know that these are other languages.
That's how gone he was.
He decked a fucking nurse dude.
Whoa.
Decked to nurse.
He was strapped down nurse or a female nurse.
He was strapped down in the fucking bed in an insane asylum in India.
He said that Jim Henson,
he elucidated Jim Henson taking him on a tour of the universe.
A stand up the fucking puppet puppet guy.
Jim Henson was God.
He elucidated the John Henson is the,
yeah,
not John.
Jim Henson was,
God took him on a tour of,
of the universe and explained to him that the reason he had taken a human
incarnation and all this was happening to him is because he'd been asked to
riddle before he was born and he couldn't come up with the answer to the riddle.
And because of that he had to be a human again.
Yeah.
Crazy shit.
But the really crazy shit is they're giving these motherfuckers in Guantanamo
Bay six times the dose of Larry Them that you're supposed to be getting and
there is no malaria in Cuba.
Oh,
it's called chemical waterboarding.
Look it up.
It's fucking nuts.
It's like chemical waterboarding.
You just get these bastards,
scoop them up from Afghanistan,
blindfold him,
fly him to fucking Cuba.
Plast and with Larry until they have no idea who they are and they'll fucking
tell you anything.
Man isn't an incredible like what they're allowed to do legally.
Like this Bradley Manning Guide,
the guy who got a this wiki leaks situation,
he's the one,
the soldier that released all the documents.
They've,
they've had this guy in solitary confinement for years now.
Like he hasn't talked to people,
he hasn't seen anything.
He sleeps with the lights on,
like he's probably completely insane by this point.
Sure.
Like to be without any human interaction.
You laying on a CGM,
so not me.
And there's you like with your work with cap backwards,
pharmacological,
waterboy,
pharmacological waterboard and get those fucking neurons all blasted with Larry
them tell them their site and you could tell them anything.
You can tell them their crabs.
That came out of hell so fucking freaky that that's us.
You know?
Remember we used to think that,
that like when we were kids it was like that was still the Soviet Union.
Did you know they were cruel,
like the way they bred that Drago and rocky for.
Yeah.
Like,
oh look,
he's,
they're so cruel and cold.
The Soviet Union does these horrible things and now we're doing that shit.
And that is that funny thing where people have this idea,
they're like,
yeah,
you know,
the United States,
we've done some stuff that maybe isn't the greatest thing ever.
We've done it to protect our citizens from terror or the idea that that kind of,
that shit that we did with like injecting people with syphilis or that all the
other crazy shit that we've done,
the idea that at some point like maybe in the 80s everyone in the government's
like let's stop being assholes.
What are we doing?
What were we thinking?
Let's just stop doing that.
Crazy shit.
Of course it still goes on.
Of course there's still the things that are going by the way,
what do they say?
And rivers in politics,
the lightest ship floats to the surface.
This stuff you know about is a million times less freaky than the shit you're
not hearing about the deep level stuff.
That's the stuff you gotta wander about man.
Cause Bradley Manning,
that's just a,
that's a show pony.
Yeah.
When you see female pumping,
you know,
500,000 coffins into the Texas and they have these camps set up,
they have these gigantic camps set up where you're like,
what is going on in here?
This high fences and these dormitories and there's armored fucking towers and
shit.
And you're like,
wait a minute.
What are these rifles towers doing here?
Like what do you have here?
There's already a room and one of those things with your fucking name on the
door,
guarantee it and youtube red band.
You guys are going to get dragged on.
What are you talking about?
You're going,
I'm fucking my sports commentator.
I'll quit this job.
I got a cyanide pill on my molar.
I'm going to snap that thing.
The moment they come to the door,
I'm undercover.
This um,
yeah,
Brian has just been a brilliant activists whole time.
You thought it was a retard.
Brian's CIA.
I've always thought that this song
that's going on right now in New York,
uh,
with this Hurricane Sandy,
it to me,
it's making me think,
you know,
of the real possibility that I'd never really considered of,
of society falling apart.
I get really fucking could fall apart.
Sure.
Like this,
you know,
one of the things they said was this is a once in a 100 year storm.
Like it's every 100 years of strong.
They actually said after it hit that they'd never had a storm.
Like that before.
But if you stop and think about it,
it's like what,
how much fucking,
how much history do we have storms,
what do we have 300 years that's reliable.
No,
I even have 300 year hired.
We have a hundred years of accurate temperature measures.
I just heard this can,
they were talking about on NPR but like a hundred years and after that you have
to start going into ice core samples and tree rings and stuff to figure it out
and then you can only figure out
late frosts and you get like a limited amount of information.
But like this could happen.
This could happen all over the fucking place.
Like we're just lucky that for the hundred years of our lives that we haven't
had more of these super storms.
The superstorms could be a regular thing.
Well it's,
I mean it's the,
I,
you know the hockey stick idea,
the hockey stick,
which is like you've got the regular temperature,
you have the general temperature of the earth and that goes on for a while.
There was like an ice age and the apparently a mini ice age in the 18 hundreds
were shit got really cold for some reason.
Maybe because of a volcano,
I can't remember.
I don't know.
I'm not a fucking geologist.
But the um,
hockey stick,
the handle,
the hockey stick represents basic temperature for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years.
And then where we're at right now is this insane acceleration and temperature
which people call global warming.
And so some people say,
well the winners are colder but they,
you know,
the global warming people are climate change.
That's something I think the scientist who uh,
came out with this research,
they feel like they shouldn't have called it global warming cause it's a
confusing term and when shit isn't warm,
people are like,
you're wrong.
It's climate change.
The idea is with the oceans get warmer,
hurricanes happen later in the season.
I've hurricanes happened later in the season.
Then they also meet up with a winter storms,
which is what this mother fucker was.
It wasn't just a hurricane,
it was a hurricane meeting like a storm.
That's normal in October.
It's like the two coming together.
It's actually three three,
fuck,
I didn't even know that it was the hurricane combining with two other storms.
That's it.
So that kind of shit is like,
you know this,
people are saying it's one once every hundred years,
but it's like,
think of fucking Katrina,
think of all the different crazy events that have been happening just in the
last 10 or 15 years.
Man.
I mean come on.
Obviously something's going down and I think there is a huge possibility that
people are just going to have to get used to moving away from the fucking oceans
or redesigning homes to like handle that shit.
While was in Montana,
we
were in a place called the bad lands and we're going down the Missouri River.
We stayed and camped mostly in this place that used to be the great western
inland sea.
And it was a warm water ocean.
So the,
the floor of this area where we're hiking was all mud.
It was like a,
like a silt,
cause it was the bottom of the fucking ocean at one point in time,
man.
And everywhere you go as you're walking up these hills as well,
the the,
the ground breaks away.
You find fossilized seashells and they could be millions of years old,
like literally millions of years old because this used to be a fucking ocean.
So it just tells us that we have to abandon this idea that we can stay wherever
we want and that this is our home and we would camp out here,
know when the climate changes,
which it does all over the,
it doesn't,
the earth doesn't give a fuck if you've got something written on a piece of
paper that says that this piece of Antartica is yours,
you can't live in Antarctic asshole.
You've got to get out of there.
And one point in time people used to be able to live in Antarctica.
They're almost positive of it.
It's a,
it's a controversial subject,
but they have a detailed map of the outside,
the like someone,
someone did an accurate map of Antarctica before it what was covered in ice,
right.
That's the only way they found it.
It's from the 15 hundreds and they know that isis existed in Antarctica for a
lot longer than that.
So it's an old fucking map.
But at one point in time,
people used to be able to go around Antarctica and they made a fucking map of
it.
Didn't people say that it was tropical there?
That it was good being,
yeah,
they don't know.
Look,
look,
there's,
there's parts of the world that have varied wildly.
I mean the Nile valley where to giant desert used to be a rainforest.
You know,
we know that rainforests receipt in the grasslands,
we know that half of North America was covering the fucking giant glacier just
14,000 years ago,
14,000 years ago.
It was like a mile high of ice and a big part of the country.
So it's like all this stuff happens.
Whether or not you're driving a Volvo,
it doesn't matter.
This stuff is,
this,
does,
this stuff has changed radically over time before any human influence at all.
So then it becomes the weird thing where people don't want to admit that we
might have some part in this.
No,
it's,
it's very political.
And it's an,
a lot of the people who are climate change deniers as they call them,
are art fundamentalists.
Yes.
Very religious people.
Yeah,
you're totally right.
You know this fucking young kid who was a marine brought it up at a Jujitsu the
other day.
It was uh,
someone was talking about climate change and he's like bap to natural process.
I mean he's stretching out and just Jujitsu Keon he's like 24.
And I'm like,
how the fuck do you know?
You know,
like there's dudes out there that are studying ice samples and core samples and
try to figure out fucking what's going on with the magnetos fear in this 24 year
old kids.
I get your natural cycle.
Just parroting this right wing talk radio version of what's going on.
Yeah,
that thing,
it's,
I think it changes,
but I also think we have something to do with it.
Well the,
the,
the fundamentalists have always
had a real fucking problem with nature.
And so whenever people like practice nature,
religion,
like when Christianity was starting to spread,
those were the people who are getting turned into fucking marshmallows is the,
what's called Pagan,
just meant country dweller.
It's people who are familiar with the cycle of the moon.
The equinoxes,
the fucking solstice is,
it's people who are like connected to the harvest,
which is where food comes from.
And the sun,
which is what makes the food grow.
So was like really connected to the earth.
And then Christianity came around with this fucking bearded,
homophobic jock who,
uh,
you know what I mean?
And that guy,
he wasn't a homophobe though.
Who,
who cry?
God.
Jesus.
No,
I'm talking about God.
His kid was a little wild,
but God,
God didn't like it.
I didn't like it.
God does not like gays.
Um,
God,
according to those people.
And God certainly doesn't like people who are slurping back fucking psychedelic
brews and having orgies and,
um,
in the forest to celebrate life that God doesn't like those people.
And so we burned them.
They burned all these fucking people.
Anyway,
the point is there's always a war on between these fundamentalists who want to
believe that the earth is some kind of endlessly renewable resource that you
could just rip into and fuck up and bomb and do whatever you want to it.
Uh,
and people who are like,
no,
this is a living organism and it's infested with these scabies,
like a bomb throwing super advanced beings that are burrowing deep,
deep into it's hide and sucking out it's blood.
Well,
literally vampires.
We were feeding off the blood of the organism.
Yes,
that's what runs our entire society is the blood of the earth.
And that's pretty incredible.
Pretty incredible.
When you really try to wrap your head around it that we,
we may very well be parasites.
I mean,
it's like that bit that I did at the beginning of my 2005 special where I talked
about how we were like mold on a sandwich,
like the mold,
you know,
we don't think of mold as individual mold spores.
We just think of it as mold.
Well,
if you looked at us from a distance,
he would look at us as like,
mold.
We're disease were,
and then I said,
we might be here to eat the sandwich.
I mean that might be what human beings are here for.
That might be why we're so far.
We'll see.
This is the fucking thing,
man.
We don't even like the,
the,
we,
we are all doing similar activities that are based almost a hundred percent on
except the accessibility of that sweet Texas tea.
But if,
if,
and that shit comes from inside the earth and it's a,
and interestingly enough,
that shit that we use to fuel our cars comes from an extinction event,
which is really quite fascinating,
is that we fuel our society on the,
um,
end result of massive changes to the planet.
And,
but the pressure's causing organic matter under the earth,
the transformative fucking oil.
It's crazy to think about that.
We fuel our cars on an ancient apocalypse.
That that's a fascinating thing.
Is it an ancient apocalypse or is it just an accumulation of dead bodies over
time?
I think it must,
I mean I think it was whatever that fucking media or impact was that destroyed
all those giant trees back then.
Thank nuts necessarily what they believe.
I think they believe that it's a continual cycle of breaking down of organic
manner and converting it into oil.
And that's why they used to call it dead dinosaurs.
But they don't do that anymore because they realize there's a lot of it is even
plant matter.
I think it's just,
no,
it's also why.
Yeah.
But that's also why a certain wells oil wells have gone dry and then actually
replenished.
Not too,
you know,
I dunno to,
to the original point that we're at is a guy wrote a book on it called a black
gold stranglehold,
I think it was.
And his contention was that the oil creation,
uh,
by the earth was a,
just a natural product of just the cycle of the earth.
It's just like something that it does and that we are looking at it like it's a,
this,
um,
this finite resource when it's in fact completely renewable.
Well,
that's true.
That's true.
There's like the two schools of thought.
So you get the peak Oilers who are like,
no man,
that shit is not renewable.
We're fucked.
That's going to run out.
And we're fucked and,
and there's no right.
What,
who's right.
God Damn,
I wish I knew you.
Don't fucking ask me.
I mean I,
I've just out of a sense of like wanting to be optimistic and having a rosy
outlook on things.
I love Ray Kurzwell.
I loved the idea that technology is going to advance to a point where we are
able to fix so many of these problems.
I tend to fall into that camp.
Like my friend Johnny Pemberton,
he's not so much,
and we always get in arguments over this cause he's like,
no,
it's just going to fucking,
it just society's like on the brink of collapse,
it's going to collapse.
Fuck your technology.
Uh,
motherboards are made of fucking petroleum products.
It doesn't matter.
Like it's so there's not enough time.
Even if we started producing solar panels now based on
the amount of his,
his version of it as based on the peak oil version.
Yes.
That's the peak oil store.
And his version is also based on,
it's,
it's sort of discounting the impact of the exponential growth of technology that
eventually someone will come up with a way to convert it.
I mean they've had,
they've got bacteria now that eats plastic,
you know what I mean?
They've got,
yes,
they can turn water into hydrogen and use it for fuel.
There's a lot of crazy shit that's going on right now.
You can't totally completely discount that.
Well I think this a simulation theory staff that I know you guys probably talk
about on this show a lot at night endlessly think about,
and Leslie,
um,
I,
I think that,
uh,
if,
if these scientists continue with their research,
which they are trying to do,
the guy that,
uh,
the,
the guy at the University of Maryland,
that theoretical physicist,
if they try,
if they can prove that we're inside a simulator,
then uh,
just from understanding that,
that kind of shit that you could theoretically do,
if this is a simulation that's running some kind of like weird,
um,
reproduction of the past,
if that's really happening,
then time travel becomes super feasible.
I definitely been thinking lately more and more that that is what the case is
because just like ridiculous things like you saying the Pokemon thing the other
day,
Joe,
the last podcast,
that was creepy to me,
like I can't stop thinking about it.
Yeah.
Why did I come up with Pokemon and he had a Pokemon outfit that he just happened
to have and then he walks in the room with it on it's,
we never talked about Pokemon before.
Never.
Never,
never.
But I reached in the back of my head.
I pull out Pokemon.
That was fucking weird.
See,
that's simulation shit.
It could be.
There's definitely,
well,
our lives are very strange.
Very,
very,
very strange.
Now,
Ari and I were talking about it last night,
you know,
we were talking about Ari's life now.
Ari and I went to play pool after I did the laugh factory last night and we're
just talking about how Ari's life has just transformed over the last two years.
He went from being a guy who couldn't get booked anywhere to a guy that is
living a dream everywhere he goes,
he's got packed houses.
They're all coming out to see him.
He's selling out like the DCM provenance,
Saturday night selling out big shows.
They could go crazy when he goes on stage and it's like all of a sudden the
world changed and went from sucky to awesome.
Yeah,
and it's like he just reached some new level of the computer game and now the
entire world that he sit his world literally is a different world.
Yes.
Like someone who's unsuccessful,
someone is unfulfilled.
Someone who's trying to accomplish something but keeps meeting with,
with,
with failure.
When,
when that happens over a long period of time you can develop like a deep despair
and the way you view the world and that's where Ari was just a couple of years
ago and now all of a sudden he's in this super happy world.
Everywhere he goes,
people are happy to see him.
He's got a big smile on his face.
He's fun to hang around with.
He's joking around a lot.
He's super positive and he's traveling to all these places and having the time
of his life.
It's like his world is a diff,
the world is a different place now.
Yeah,
it's,
well this is why I love the fucking multiverse theory.
I love the idea that we exist in a place where every single possible event is
happening at once.
Everything that couldn't happen is happening.
It's all happening in one great eternal burst of happening ness.
And that you can shift yourself from different nodes of where you are now to
more desirable nodes of the multiverse,
the places that you want to be.
And that's what goals are,
you know,
goals,
goal.
Having a goal is a form of uh,
visualizing the specific note of the multiverse that you would like to be
existing in and the contrast between that place and where we currently are.
And it's like a grappling hook that you're throwing through infinity and it
lands at this place that you can visualize and then you kind of pull yourself to
that place through action over there.
No Dude.
Like the things that you put in the front of the line,
like the
not gnomes to know.
What's the nose to know?
You're going to have to read before you get into this conversation.
Well,
you have to go Google that dude.
I wish I was talking about,
no,
go ahead.
Continue.
So anyway,
so the idea is like these fucking movements through the multiverse,
as you move towards what you want to become,
uh,
I feel like a,
a symptom that you're moving towards this new universe that's possible for
everyone is that synchronicities start happening in the same way that like when
you're in a boat,
you can see ripples in the water.
And when you begin to really focus and move towards a place that you want to be,
regardless of whatever the fuck that place is,
if you really start working going in that direction,
that's when the Juju starts happening.
Weird coincidences,
strange fucking moments that you consider like,
man,
the probability of that happening is so incredibly fucking low.
There's no way that that could happen.
And it's quite often absurd.
It's novelty.
It's like what?
You're just talking about fucking Pokemon.
Brian coming out in a Pokemon outfit.
This isn't like Tesla having a vision for the fucking,
for alternating current.
It's just absurd and silly,
but it still fills you with a momentary sense of novelty.
This kind of like,
wow,
this place is pretty fucking cool.
I feel like that happened
Boone's the more I'm tuned into life correctly and the multiverse theory as I've
understood it,
is also based on,
well,
one of the operating theory is,
is that every decision that you make,
every direction that you go and every choice that you make literally opens up a
completely new universe.
Yes.
It's like,
it's almost like we're cavemen learning like a language,
but the government or somebody already knows the language,
like we're like learning how to be like,
oh,
we can.
I don't think they do.
I think it's a massive mystery to all involved.
I think the government understands that they have a certain amount of power and
they don't want to let it go,
which is what typically all corrupt people do once they get into a position of
control.
Yeah.
It takes a massive amount of control over your ego to be in a position of power
and still be moral and ethical and kind and loving to be in a position of
ultimate control.
Like if you were in the CIA or that you ran the NSA or something like that,
to to be there and have compassion for all of brotherhood and all of all of
mankind.
It's really hard to do.
It's really hard.
It's way easier to be a corrupt cunt and just sort of control shit.
Sure.
But it is possible.
It is possible.
If it's possible for any one person to be moral and ethical and loving and kind
and still be a powerful person and still be a strong and accomplished person,
it is possible to be that.
So it's possible to run a government that's like that too.
It's just they have to understand what a massive position they're in.
Instead of thinking,
well,
this is what makes life easier.
This is what makes our job easier.
This is what makes it to clamp down on terror instead of looking at it that way.
If they just looked at it like literally in what is best for mankind.
Yes,
that's it man.
It can be done totally.
It can be done.
And I think that even thinking along those lines helps to change the world.
Like it sounds like totally Hokey,
but I think having this conversation and knowing this conversation is going to
easily reach a million people,
several million people probably over the course of,
you know,
the next few months.
Yeah.
This conversation is going to enter it.
It's going to be data that enters into certain people's minds.
And that's the kind of thoughts that we need.
We need,
do we need an understanding that yes,
government is important?
Yes.
Police are important because people are imperfect and they need also to be
protected from themselves.
They need to be stopped and they tried to drunk drive.
They need to be that.
We need someone who can protect people from people that are bullies and people
that fuck up and get their,
let their emotions take control themselves.
We absolutely need that.
But we also need a very strong moral backbone to this country that we're
completely missing.
And we need our eyes,
our mental eyes,
and our spiritual eyes moved in the direction of we need a philosophy.
Yeah,
a story.
Not just laws and also,
but there's also the story of the government,
the narrative of the government,
the narrative of the news,
the narrative of like a media that's giving out information is inevitably a
terrible catastrophic narrative and it will always be whenever you turn on the
fucking news,
it's a disaster.
And I'm not just talking fucking frankenstorm.
I'm talking about,
Oh God.
If you believe the news,
then you believe all pitbulls are evil.
You believe pit have climbed out of some fucking volcano and how and are just
ravaging the world.
Chewing the phases.
I've senior citizens,
if you believe the fucking news,
you believe that there's,
you would have believed the Africanized bees were coming.
Communists are attacking.
Al Qaeda is marching into our streets to destroy us,
satanist or molesting our fucking kids,
and that all politics is corrupt and evil and that the entire planet is on the
verge of some ecological catastrophe.
Well,
the real issue is that there's too many people.
There's 300 million people in this country alone.
You cannot concentrate in one hour on the,
on the news without getting an insane amount of negative shit.
But because you're dealing with individual acts over 300 million,
right?
So this is exactly,
so that's where they're,
they're at.
That's where they are directing the consciousness and the attention of all of
humanity,
uh,
into these,
basically anomalies.
Um,
and if you look at the amount of people right now and the small amount of
catastrophe that's happening,
comparing that,
compared to how many of us there are,
it's a fucking miracle every day.
We've talked about this a hundred times,
uh,
that,
you know,
this is a way safer time than there's ever been in human history.
Yeah.
But when you look at people like trying to pass laws to take away rights,
you would think that there's riding in the streets and that the world is falling
apart.
Right?
So how do you,
what's hot?
What does that connection like?
Why is it that with this time where really like things have never been better
for the human race?
Why is there still this overwhelming need to crack down further and further on
rights and liberties and control the population more and more North Korea style?
Why is that?
Well,
I mean,
I think that you,
it's a trite thing to say,
but it's,
you follow the money.
And so I think that if you look in and see that,
you know,
what is it,
48% of people in the prisons or it's drug related offenses,
if you see like the people who are making money off of these lots,
I mean God knows how much money the fucking TSA make selling their crazy gear
that they have.
You know,
that's a big fucking business,
you know?
So I think it's just some people tend to profit off of the mass perception that
we are existing in a sort of held dimension.
And there's people who figured out a way to suckle at the,
those blacks say titanic teats and extract money from it that they use for their
own sense gratification.
Their own self.
Yeah.
And it's a tiny amount of people.
Really.
Yeah.
Statistically speaking,
if you look at the greater number of human beings in this country,
300 million people,
how many of them are sucking the blood out of the earth?
Is it even a thousand?
You know,
does he,
is it even a thousand industrialists and bankers that are responsible for
wielding that kind of
to tonight?
How many of them are masons?
Duncan,
Prosser,
all Mason's brother Joe.
But you're here.
But here's the thing,
man.
I think that,
you know,
the stuff that we kind of hit upon when we have these conversations,
um,
I think that that kind of stuff is,
if people's eyes start turning in the direction of the idea as absurd and
quixotic is,
it might sound that you can,
through a combination of discipline and visualization,
create a positivity singularity in your life where you,
your very being in everything around you can like almost like being in an
elevator,
going up a few floors into paradise that can happen where suddenly you discard
like a snake shedding its skin,
all the foul ness of your,
uh,
of the,
of the fear calcifications that have formed around your life.
And the form of bad relationship,
shitty friends,
uh,
a negative outlook.
You can like drop all that and suddenly experienced some version of rebirth.
You know,
this is why the Christian idea of being born again as a beautiful notion,
that's a crazy idea to play around with the idea that you can renew and
rejuvenate your life completely if you just let go of fear and turn your fucking
eyes away from the ghost story that these hell buzzards are,
are spoon feeding us so that they can sell droids and fucking Fords.
And if you start turning from that and putting your focus on this,
id is not,
you're not always going to be perfect.
I mean,
you're not going to be suddenly in the garden of Eden.
People who need to change their idea of the people that are actually doing that,
not the people that are like buying into it.
It's way more important to have the people that are in control changed their
idea.
So how the fuck do you get to the Lizard?
Well,
the,
to get to the fucking lizard,
it's man,
I think that what would have to happen would be a,
uh,
kind of,
an exponential shift in the,
uh,
consciousness and the predilections of the majority of people on Earth so that
people start,
you know,
playing around with some,
some of this fucking awesome information that's floating out there and see if
you can make yourself happy.
So that's where it's,
there's a possibility of technology aiding in the evolution because if there
comes a technology that allows data to be distributed,
probably wireless,
probably point to point inside something that's installed in a person's body,
like some sort of a chip that's installed in your body.
And there'll be some sort of a wireless data network that's like an intranet for
human beings communicate with each other and you're going to be able to access
the ones and zeroes that make up your own fucking personality too.
And people are going to have Yelp scores,
like you're gonna meet someone,
you'll see like two stars over their head.
You're like,
oh,
look at this asshole.
Yeah,
they're going to be just like,
excuse,
it's going to be like rating restaurants on Yelp.
You'll meet someone and as you look at them,
little cursor over them and you'll see stars and you can't resist that.
You're gonna,
you're gonna have to go through with that.
And when,
when that does happen,
then all the people in government are going to be like,
fuck,
I have zero stars.
Like I'm a content.
They're going to be forced to recognize that all the people around them are
going to be forced to look at them.
And when the soldiers look at the,
the generals and all these shit heads that are running the army and they see
zero stars over their head and they realize how fucked up they are as human
beings.
I remember Joe is the Leicas currencies.
Remember Facebook likes long time ago,
we talked about likes currencies.
Remember when we said that likes and Facebook's a was going to be a currency in
the future.
Yeah.
It could very well be,
but I think it'll definitely be a way to um,
to like look at a person and get a read on who they are before you ever start
the,
I mean a person is directly who you are is directly related to how other people
feel about you when you're around,
you know that that is a big part of who you are as a human.
It's how you interact with the rest of the species.
Well,
if there was like a rating system,
like a Yelp for people like that,
that you just saw when you met someone,
people would try,
oh so much fucking harder to be nicer.
You know,
they would try so much harder to fit in and they would feel the repercussions of
having that zero stars over their head.
Man.
When people are cons,
if you really consider why people are cons,
my theory on it is that they don't understand how important they are.
They think they're not important.
Usually when someone's being a cunt,
it's easy to be a con,
but,
but it's because you're not,
this is something we want to lash out.
When Hancock came on my podcast,
he,
uh,
talked about ios skinned slurping,
ios skin.
How one of the effects was that it made you experience the way you made people
throughout your life feel.
You know,
like they talk about the life review when you go into the light and that shit.
It's like they say that,
I've heard,
I've talked to people who've like died and come back and they say,
it's not that you like watch a video of your life,
it's that you literally see the way that you made the people around you feel.
You feel that you feel the way you made the people around you feel.
And I think that most people who are Dicks,
they don't think they're important enough to induce any kind of feeling.
And the people around them,
they don't even think that they're important enough to make someone feel like
shit necessarily.
I don't know.
I agree with that at all.
I don't think that's what's going on at all.
I think they're just unhappy and they lash out.
I think that's what being a dick is.
It's a projection thing.
They are trying to hurt people's feelings for sure.
When someone's being an asshole,
they want to have a reaction just to let them know that they're important.
I don't think that,
it's not that they don't feel like they're important.
I think their egos out of control,
which is just the opposite of not feeling that they're important.
They're important is more important than anything else in the world.
That's where they're willing to lash out.
Yep.
People,
you know,
man,
I like,
I don't want to think that way because I like it.
It's an ego issue.
I liked it.
What I let,
here's why I like to think,
speak and write the note of the multiverse.
I want to exist.
Then I want to exist in this note of the multiverse where underneath all that,
all the ego calcifications and all this shitty lashing out thing.
It's just a super sweet person that happens to have been just walked out of some
briny swamp that consists of their family,
their job,
their life,
their past,
whatever it is,
and they're still dripping with some of the oozing stagnation of being born in
a,
in a bad incarnation.
And the way that that's manifesting is the form of their shitty activities.
But underneath that fucking thing like a mask,
it's just a person who like had a run through a stinky swamp and needs,
you know,
needs to shower off
mutually exclusive cause that's exactly what I'm saying.
The,
the person who lashes out,
they're angry.
You know the person who lashes out there trying to hurt people's feelings.
It's not that they don't think they're worthwhile,
it's that their ego is protecting them from their environment because they've
grown up in a hostile,
yeah.
Well,
okay,
well I'll make it obvious.
Concession hundred percent of 100% of people.
Certainly there is some percentage that pride has some bike things.
They're fucking important.
God knows you run into people or popped up all day.
Do.
Yeah.
But quite often,
man,
I think that that,
that puffed up thing underneath it,
they don't really think they're fucking him.
I'm saying some people definitely think they're important,
but they don't really believe they're important.
Yeah.
They don't really think they're worth something.
They don't really think that they're,
they're,
they're part of,
uh,
a web of life that that has value.
They just feel like they're fucking worthless shit bags and,
and,
and so they put on a show.
See,
I think that what's going on primarily with people is that when you see people
that are acting illogically and you see people that are just angry with road
rage,
there's not a of consideration going on at all.
And I think most of what they're operating on his momentum,
so they're not really even thinking about whether they're worthwhile or not
worthwhile there.
There they're about ego there about reacting to,
about anger and frustration and there about selfishness.
And when you,
when you live a life,
especially when you have a job that just sucks the fucking blood out of your
body literally sucks the inspiration out of your soul.
Do you want to be selfish when you're done?
I think that's a,
a big part of road rage,
a big part of people yelling at you don't even want to give someone a few
seconds to get in front of you with the car.
You want to honk your horn and give them the finger cause they made you wait a
second or two.
I mean,
well you're having seat,
you're having an ego ish seizure.
You're having these kinds of seizures than the way they are coming out as and
you being a dick,
but you're just,
it's like a muscle spasms.
It's,
but it's all a fucking result of this kind of like,
you know,
unfortunate,
whatever the fucking thing that your past is,
is happening in your path,
your programming.
So,
so it's like this,
I will just love this fucking idea that this is called unconditional positive
regard.
If you ever heard this term before,
unconditional positive regard.
So it's this idea that if you can manifest around people a state of
unconditional positive regard,
it doesn't matter what,
how they're acting without judging them.
Just this NCI.
A lot of us came into this fucking dimension and her freaking the fuck out.
Lots of us are rightfully freaking the fuck out.
Some of us,
maybe we should,
we're freaking out when we shouldn't be.
But if someone's freaking out,
they're freaking the fuck out.
So the way to handle that as to manifest something called unconditional positive
regard,
this is a psychological theory.
And so there was like,
I can't remember the therapist's name,
but you know,
they would take kids who are like about to go to Juvie or whatever from schools
and they would bring these kids to meet with him because he's a therapist.
And these kids have been meeting with therapists their whole lives because
they're fuck ups and so are,
um,
they're,
uh,
experience has always been one of being in offices where someone's trying to
change them and turn them into something different,
make them feel bad for the way they are.
Bam.
Or some kind of ethical system into their brain,
whatever.
So this guy started doing this thing where he'd let the kids come into his
office and he'd just sit there with them.
There's like crayons,
shit,
they can draw on.
They would do their crazy shit.
They're little act outs and freak outs,
but the whole time he was just trying to like be a person with them who wasn't
judging them,
who wasn't looking down on them and thinking of them as monsters and so the
effect of this,
these,
this shit that he did,
it's a whole,
I wish I could remember the name of it.
It's a whole goddamn type of therapy,
but the end result is these kids,
their grades started improving.
They started to become better people because they were in the presence of
someone who is actively trying to like a preciate them as human
beings.
Of course.
Look,
we can all agree that the number one problem with the society is the way human
beings are raised.
Human beings are raised by idiots,
raised in a a really uncomfortable way with it,
never developed.
They never truly developed character.
Never truly develop
a philosophy or a point of view that that aids them in life.
How many people go through life like perfectly,
perfectly program?
How many people go,
go through life with a really positive experience of growing up,
but very few.
That's a real,
the real issue because then those people become adults.
They raised their own children and they try to correct as much as possible.
But you know,
who knows how much of them has been fucked because of their childhood and,
and continues on.
And on what I was saying,
even when we're talking about the people that run the world,
you know,
that we need a philosophy for how human beings interact with each other.
A code that's never broken,
an agreement between all others.
And that,
that,
that to me is the most important thing that the human human race can establish.
There is a way you can be successful while having all those things.
And that's what people don't understand.
There's a lot of people that think that,
well,
you've got to do what you gotta do to make in this world.
No,
you don't.
That's not true.
That's not necessary.
There's a lot of businesses that act totally,
completely ethically,
you know,
um,
there's a lot of businesses that get by without fucking people over.
You just do it the right way.
Life can move in the right direction and we can still have success and
prosperity.
It is 100% fucking possible.
And the idea that the two things are mutually exclusive,
it's a fucking dirty lie that's been told to you by crux and the world right now
is run by those crux.
They are running the world.
When you see all these different bills that are being passed that are slowly
eroding the rights of American citizens and,
and slowly taking away your liberties and slowly making it easier for them to
spy on you,
that is not someone looking out for your best interest.
It just isn't,
they aren't looking out for the human race as a whole.
They just aren't.
That's not the right way to approach it.
That is the way it should had approaches it.
And so that's,
it's becomes very obvious that we need to overhaul the system that,
that our country operates under,
that the world operates under.
Because right now it's operating under a shithead dictator system and they don't
need to be that way.
That's the real issue.
The real issue is they don't need to be that way.
They're that way because they're incompetent that that way because they're
unhappy and you can't run the world like a cut and still be a happy person.
You're just,
you're not going to have as much benefit even in your own life and our problem
is we don't look at the world.
We don't look at our life.
We don't look at our existence as you know,
what is the most important thing?
Well done,
but the abundance of happiness,
love Pr.
No,
no,
no.
We looked at it as money.
We look at it as money as the number one most important thing and the more that
you can accumulate,
the more you're correct.
That's something that has to shift.
Money is just simply a part of a good equation and really the money that you
need to be happy as enough money so that you don't have to think about money.
It's an ironic thing,
you,
you want enough money so that you can eat and have a roof over your head and be
able to enjoy the comforts of home,
a nice couch and Norton normal shit.
That that is really the money that you need in this,
this life to,
to have happiness,
health and money,
to support health,
money to support nutrition monies,
support,
shelter.
And once you have that,
that is everything that is,
will,
real happiness comes from.
And if you don't have that,
but yet you have millions and millions of dollars,
you're sick.
You've missed the point.
Yeah.
Missed the most important part of the equation.
The most important part of the equation is companionship,
friendship,
love,
happiness,
safety,
shelter,
community,
all of those things first.
Yeah.
Then more money.
I mean,
if you really can become some Richard Branson ballers seems to have good Karma
and yet has a spaceship,
you know,
I mean,
you have more power to you.
The guy seems to have good Karma and yet still has these amazing,
but more important than anything is the first aspect of it.
So when you see someone who's fucking completely miserable and the rich as shit
and they're evil is fuck,
that's a huge disaster.
That's just a huge imbalance and a huge fuck up for them.
Like they don't understand that you've got to give up some of that to achieve
happiness and peace and love and friendship and community.
And it's still possible.
Have you ever heard the term,
the higher taste?
Have you ever heard that term before?
No.
So the idea is that there's a connection.
Take those glasses off.
You're freaking me out.
Come on,
let me,
well,
Oh man,
they're my Waco glasses.
There's the idea that you can,
um,
connect.
Now,
a lot of people don't like the word God,
so get rid of that fucking word.
But there's the idea that you can connect with a kind of infinite flow of
energy.
This is the shit that Tesla talked about.
This the shit that a lot of people have come in contact with this fucking thing.
And they have a lot of different words for this fucking thing.
But the idea is that once you begin to connect with that thing or even flirt
with the connection to that thing and figure out ways to like really establish
that,
when you begin to feel what that feels like,
that sense of connection,
that sense of being in the flow,
being in harmony,
that thing,
you can't buy that feeling.
There's no way money is ever going to buy that feeling and it's a feeling that
makes any kind of,
it makes everything else just seem like icing on the cake.
And I think a lot of these people have just simply gotten disconnected.
They're like a garden hose with a kink in it.
They're not getting like an energetic flow.
They're eating plastic and have this kind of existential nutritional deficiency
that manifests in the form of an outbreak of cantinas and it's like it's mostly
just because they haven't made that big fucking connection.
The connection people make through psychedelics,
the connection people make through chanting.
Yeah.
I really don't think that you can become a fully developed the developed
human being,
unless you have some,
some of series of events in your life more than one,
that that breakdown your vision of the world and provide you with deeper
insight.
It doesn't have to be psychedelics.
It could be all sorts of different life experiences.
It could be traveling,
it can be meditation.
It can be deep consideration for the world and constant,
constant overview and a constant audit of your thoughts and the way you know you
interact with people and your happiness and where it comes from.
I think all of that,
all of those are possibilities.
Those are all,
there's different ways to achieve the same effect,
but,
but unless you do have those things,
you're going to be a child.
You're going to die.
And old child,
you really never gonna understand that you've been tricked by your own ego.
He had been tricked by your own ego first of all,
into thinking that this is somehow or another permanent.
It is unquestionably a temporary experience.
You got to enjoy the shit out of it.
You got to have as much fun as you can while it's going on,
but you better be treating it like what it is cause it's fucking temporary and
you're leaving behind a wake and a ripple of shit that is going to go from,
from you onto your ancestors and your shitty kids that you've raised and,
and all the other different people that you've impacted in your life.
You've created a horrible ripple of shit because you are imbalanced.
Yeah,
but they don't have to be,
they don't have to be.
That's the thing.
If all these fucking,
you know,
these guys that are in state secret societies and skull and bones and shit,
if they all just dropped the bullshit,
stop being pussies and took mushrooms,
the whole picture would change immediately.
You would have looked at.
And folks,
this is not,
you know,
I'm not making this up.
Look at John Hopkins University studies on silicide been use and what,
what happened to people with one siliciden and experience over the course of a
couple of years,
their personalities changed for the better.
He's pussies.
They need to stop dressing up like fucking eyes wide.
Shut and bone and each other in the ass of videotape and holding each other
hostage with the,
the information instead of doing it that way,
they need to get together and do some fucking mushrooms.
Right?
Yeah,
man,
it's,
it's such an important thing to make this connection however you do it.
Mckenna was really into mushrooms cause it's an expeditious way to do it.
And he had,
he was a believer in 2012 and the idea of some kind of,
uh,
eschatological event that was going to wipe us all out.
So we got to move quick,
uh,
around dos as I need.
I actually didn't believe that he is,
his idea was ultimate novelty,
but he seemed to be in a rush.
He has,
his thing was like,
you're not going to get people to like your,
this,
this transformation of society you're talking about.
He may be fairly recognized that like,
let's make this shit happen fast.
And the fastest way to deal with be to get everyone or as many people as
possible to experience the psychedelic state and bring that into the world
through our actions.
No,
he,
he didn't really believe in the end of the world for 2012.
That's what I'm saying.
He thought it was going to be a time machine.
He thought it was going to be some,
some moment of ultimate novelty that it was going to be a technological thing.
Right.
Well I write,
I,
yeah,
I guess when I say the end of the world,
I mean like his idea was more of a positive into the world scenario but still
the apocalypse lifting of the veil,
transformation of the old ways and to some complete like complete moment of
novelty and like he was into like the reason I'm just trying to get to the point
that he liked to like he placed mushrooms over meditation where there is other
people you say,
um,
you know,
the problem with the psychedelic experience is that it gets you there and it
gets you there quick.
But you got to come back out of that and the idea is to like how can we be in
that state of consciousness?
Not like the walls are melting,
but in that state of connectivity all the time.
Well,
we know a lot of people that have had a series of these psychedelic experiences
and they're still like really selfish.
No,
we know this one guy was very angry who said a lot of a mushroom experiences.
I mean a ton writes books on it.
He's angry motherfucker.
The contrary to the vision of the plan itself,
the fungus itself,
right?
So because it's a teacher,
it's just like any other
you can decline and ignore it.
And also if you've got some weird social issues and psychological issues,
you can start having grandiose ideas based on psychedelic experiences.
Like I've,
I've talked to people that had psychedelic experiences and believed that like
there's a whole team of,
uh,
beings out there that are looking out for them and helping them succeed and
succeed.
For what?
Like what is,
what's the end goal?
Like what are you talking about?
Like you really believe that it's like they've chosen to like look at only a
fraction of the information that's being displayed
exceeds,
see this is that brilliant too because that's the thing is like with meditation,
sometimes I'll go into meditation with a point like I'm trying to get something,
I'm trying to do something I'm trying to get like in my mind wants there to be a
result.
Like you know,
some kind of like metaphysical tricep development or something through
meditation because we've been taught to,
to be completely a result oriented to live a result oriented life.
And the paradox of meditation is the idea is like,
no,
you don't get anything out of this.
This isn't the,
it's entering into a mind state where you're no longer constantly in the pursuit
of the future.
You're no longer always chasing whatever the thing is that you think is the
moment in the future.
You are uh,
coming into where you are at this very moment.
Wherever the fuck you happen to be.
You know,
fucking lotion all over your day cause you just jerked off to porn or fucking
with beer cans all over your fucking house or wherever you are.
You get into that moment and become that thing.
And that paradox of being fully in that thing is that your situations and
conditions will begin to transform because that's where the real like healing
happening.
The real transformation doesn't start with a fucking beating yourself up.
It starts with a sense of like,
all right,
hold on.
Okay.
Uh,
entry into this dimension created a form of weird amnesia.
I apparently have developed the fucking personality of a supreme cont.
I've got some weird fucking hangover that came from my incarnation in this
dimension.
I'm going to shake off this hangover and the way I'm going to shake it off is by
fully understanding where I'm at right now.
It's a paradox,
man.
It's something that's like a really strange thing because to get to a place
where you aren't such a con and where you aren't trapped,
you need to first understand that what your prison cell is like.
Isn't that fascinating?
We seal these roles.
Truett guys like get rid of about another one the other day who's realized that
his fund had lost hundreds of millions dollars.
So he committed suicide.
Yes,
exactly do this like strange numbers,
these abstract numbers that are part of this game.
And he realized that the game was over.
Wife,
kids,
the whole deal children.
He had children.
Did you see,
did you see the fucking guy who burned his house down and took a cyanide pill in
court?
Do you see that video?
Yes.
Holy Shit Dude.
He's like fucking,
that's it man.
He said he pressed reset cause he's going to jail.
But like he was going to jail for a long time so he decided to take that Sinai
pill right in front of everybody.
Yeah,
man.
Sinai Dude fucking,
I looked up how that shit kills you.
It's goddamn crazy dude.
He just sat there.
Yeah,
the pill.
And just sat there and started snoring.
Yeah.
Then his body just started giving up and then he collapsed.
They're like call,
call,
call hospital called nine one one.
He's down John Moaning.
And
because it is or the problem,
man,
this is like fucking,
you know,
it's so funny out.
The Bible's rife with right,
really great information.
But if you take it literally,
it's retarded.
But the Bible is always like the god of the Bible is always against false idols.
And he's always saying,
you know,
don't worship false idols.
If you worship false idols,
you're fucked.
And people like that,
you know,
they started this crazy worship of a bullshit and the end result is you end up
in a pretty fucking crappy I extinction event happened.
How does this all play out?
Because this is all just assuming that the world is real.
Now we're,
we're assuming that the world is some sort of a computer simulation.
And by the way,
this keeps coming to me.
Even Brittany Palmer sent me a tweet the other day about a computer simulation
code.
Very bright girl,
by the way,
even though she's a ring card girl.
Fucking Badass.
It's fascinating.
There's a card girl.
There's a ring card girl that's into simulation theory.
Any Palmer's bad ass bitch.
She's a cool chick.
That's Jesus.
She's the incarnation of Jesus.
Her uh,
her boyfriends and do it too apparently.
Cause he sent all right.
Sent a link to these for me to read.
The boyfriend thinks that way.
Great.
Handsome Fella had some very successful,
you're fucked.
You're not getting in their kid.
Uh,
but um,
the uh,
the,
that idea though,
the simulation theories going around the world,
a lot of people
are looking at it and one of the reasons,
one of the rig,
the real big ones that sort of catapulted it was when,
uh,
this guy,
Dr. Gates,
uh,
has found hidden error correction codes hidden in the equations of
supersymmetry.
It's,
this is really,
really hard to wrap your head around,
but in his words,
um,
they had found the presence of codes in the equations of physics,
not that they were trying to compute something and the way he describes the
citizens a little bit like doing biology where if you studied an animal,
you'd eventually run into it's DNA.
And that's essentially what's happened to us.
These codes that we found,
they're like the DNA that sits inside of the equations that we study.
So yeah.
Do we live in the Matrix?
Yeah.
Well man,
it's a blast.
I mean,
the reason it's fucking cool is it because it's a,
um,
it's a new,
it's a new version of a very old idea that's being told using the current state
of the yard,
uh,
language that we have today.
But this idea of the universe being a computer simulation that Maya is,
they call it an India,
which means illusion.
This is a very old fucking idea.
John.
Um,
John Wheeler,
John Archibald Wheeler was an American theoretical physicist who was largely
responsible according to,
uh,
the,
the biology,
the biograph,
um,
the biography on them largely responsible for reviving interest in general
relativity in the United States after World War II.
And one of the things that Dr. Gates had said was that he thought the wheeler
was crazy and he believes that this experience,
you know,
studying this computer code and,
and finding out that there's code in supersymmetry,
he says if you study physics long enough,
you might become crazy.
And that like literally if you delve deep into the heart of matter,
yeah.
If you really get to the nitty gritty of what life really is,
it's undeniable that it's some sort of a code.
It's undeniable that it is some sort of,
I'm wouldn't say it's a computer simulation because the term simulation,
like I joke around about the fact that I believe that human beings are living in
some video game in the future and that we really looked like the aliens and that
that's,
yeah.
But what I really think might be going on is that the reality as it as it
stands,
has many more elements to it than just things you can hit and knock on with your
knuckles.
Things you could beat with a hammer,
throw water on.
I think there's a lot more than the solid physical matter of the universe that
we are not totally taking into consideration.
And I always bring up the idea of the imagination that we look at the
imagination as well.
Can I was a kid,
you know,
oh he's got such a vivid imagination cause I would lie about shit.
You know,
may draw pictures and make up things.
Yeah.
But what the imagination really is is this,
this hail of ideas in your mind that if followed through manifest physical
things in this reality.
So it's not simply just this airy fairy woo thing that's like this in that non
important intangible aspect of life.
No,
it's the creator of everything.
It's the root behind the creation of every single physical thing from nuclear
power plants to guns to fucking cat clocks.
All that shit is created by the imagination.
It's a piece of all of that shit.
It's a laboratory.
It's an owl chemical laboratory that exists in your mind and that's one aspect
and another aspect is the exact vibration you put out there.
The love that you put out there,
the friendship that you put out there,
the,
the happiness that you bring to people.
You know,
look we were experiencing it in a form with this whole podcast network thing
because all of us together,
you know having podcasts,
all of us together pushing this happy positive,
you know sort of vibe out there and then having all these happy positive people
come to the shows and experiencing a direct result of this creating this way of
thinking where people are coming up to us on a daily fucking basis.
Last night at the laugh factory had a bunch of dudes came up to me and said the
same thing,
you're changing my life.
You changed my life,
changed the way I look at things,
change the web.
I'm like happier now.
I was going through a bad breakup,
I was fat,
I lost weight,
I got healthy.
It's all the same thought.
Re Re re repeating itself over and over and over again and that thought is that
you're putting out a positive thing and positive results are being accumulated
because of this transmission.
That's right man.
In earlier you're talking about this being technologically enhanced.
Well it is technologically enhanced.
This is it.
Your using a technological amplifier to blast positive energy out into the world
and it's exponentially increasing the positivity that just starts in this room
with a couple of microphones and that creates big fucking shifts
and not just positive energy but a positive philosophy that you can use.
You can actually apply and get direct results.
It will inspire you and you can apply it.
Also a philosophy that is being is open source and the sense that the people
you're blasting it out to,
at least my experience has been some of these people email you shit you've never
heard before,
books you've never heard before and then that gets added to it,
applied to it and woven into this fucking awesome thing which is essentially
just like a internet salon.
It's a kind of salon in the old idea of what it was,
which was where a group of people would get together and talk about philosophy.
Well it's where the wood Twitter comes into play is the ability to exchange
links in the short form where you're going to read them.
People send me emails.
Jesus Christ,
some of you crazy fucks that send me these 17 page emails on your whole life.
Yeah,
no one's reading that.
Stop it.
Stop being fucking crazy.
But if you send me some shit about like self concrete.
Yes.
Did you read that yet?
It's amazing.
Self healing concrete go piss dude.
So there's some shit called self repairing bio concrete that's made out of
bacteria.
I mean is like every day it's getting weirder and weirder and weirder and it
just does not seem to be ending man.
It's all going on while we're not even paying attention while you're just doing
your everyday thing there.
They're constantly coming up with new crazier and crazier shit and this stuff is
called it's bacterial spores that are added to the concrete mix and they're
activated by water and this experimental concrete.
It patches up cracks by itself.
I mean this is fucking bananas man.
It's con start growing feelings in the future.
Yeah,
it's gonna be like we can't drive on the road cause it hurts.
Well wouldn't it be crazy if your house became like something you could talk to?
Hey I'm home.
How old are you?
And you like touch the walls and it's like happy to see you and shit.
I mean that doesn't seem outside the realm of possibility.
Go into the attic once in a while at the house.
No,
what's his boss?
Yeah,
fuck it.
Fuck it.
Fuck his brain in the attic.
Well when you,
when you stop and think about it,
like if we do come up with smart computers,
what if one of the things that we do is make your whole house like a living
network?
Crazy.
Yeah.
Like you come home and your house like literally like it feeds off of your
positive feelings.
Like your house is like,
is it cold enough for you?
It was a warm enough for you.
Would you like the lights on and you're like,
can you turn on channel 20?
Yeah.
20 Ding Dong home shopping network.
You know,
you could do whatever the fuck you want through through communicating with your
house.
You tell it when to turn the lights on,
tell when to turn the lights out.
That's all coming.
Your House is going to be like one giant computer.
You're not even going to reach for the Faucet.
You're going to say turn the hot water on.
And then if you had like an Asian Fed as you'd buy like an Asian theme type
looking house or if you liked that,
you know,
like Western girl or like a rant
double.
Yeah,
your house.
You'd be like really like a muted Japanese lady that's super polite and shy.
Yeah.
Hi.
Yeah,
you could,
your house could talk to you.
I mean,
it could have a voice.
Do you remember when you,
this is a true story,
Brian.
Uh,
Brian was dating this chick and she got jealous of his navigation system because
it was a hot girls.
Yeah,
she made me change it.
Do I guys so choose the British guy,
but then I acted,
I would pay for him every time he talked to me.
Isn't that hilarious?
And someone could actually be jealous of the navigation systems voice.
That's when you know you've got a rock solid relationship.
When you chill,
when you check is upset at the navigation.
This is fucking hard.
Tell us where to go is where the Dan left here.
Oh,
I hate this girl's voice.
Fake computer was even better.
It was like a Tom Tom and with Tom Tom's you can download like celebrity voices.
So I started dating.
It was like Cameron Diaz or something like that.
But we can do that.
Yeah,
you're going to do yoga and like,
oh,
did you guys hear about fucking star wars getting bought by Disney?
That's ridiculous.
Do you think that's good
or bad?
Um,
well look,
let's be honest.
The last star wars movie sucked a fat one.
Yeah,
they all sucked.
They sucked.
And Ari was saying that,
you know,
we're just in denial that if you go back and try to watch star wars,
it sucked too.
And I say it didn't suck because it only sucks today if you compare it to the
movies of today.
But if you go back to the,
when star wars was released,
it was groundbreaking.
Man.
There's no denying.
It's like saying that if you go back and listen to Lenny Bruce,
she won't laugh.
It doesn't matter.
It's still like super groundbreaking.
Have you seen the video of the pre voice over Darth Vader?
No.
The guy who did Darth Vader's voice before Morgan Freeman did it.
I'm your father.
It's fucking opposite.
Morgan Freeman.
Not Morgan Freeman.
I'm fuck.
Wow.
That is phrase is the guy awesome voices.
Yeah.
Who Was it?
The guy who did a,
he was in Tulsa.
Doom in Conan to the fuck's his name.
Really?
The guy with a black guy commercials.
Lots of commercials.
What the fuck's his name?
Earl Jones.
James Road drums.
Yeah,
that guy.
Yeah.
Um,
but if you go back and watch those star wars movies,
like there was a couple of good ones there were decent,
they were great for the time,
but the new ones are fucking terrible man.
They're just terrible.
It's like George Lucas,
like lost his connection.
It's,
it's really sad.
It's like the guy needs to do squats and run some hills.
Squats is not going to make star wars.
He's got a,
he's got like no life to them.
It's like there's no passion there.
There's no fire.
There's no,
there's no,
there's no real threat.
It's just all just mush.
It's just mushy,
Mush,
stupidity.
I just hope like they don't have like George,
our banks.
Like Disney's like,
no,
we're going to reinvent jar jar.
He's going to be a vampire this time.
Yeah.
I wouldn't have a sexy kid,
George.
Our banks,
like what the fuck was that?
That's like the just take taking an [inaudible] and just removing everything
that's good about it and adding more stupidity.
And,
and what's even creepier is when they change it.
Like they just rereleased us all the Star Wars on Blu Ray and I guess they did
all of these things like making the walks and blink now cause they didn't use to
blank,
I guess.
I don't remember.
But,
uh,
but like now that's even creepier because now you know that saying,
yeah,
you know that they fixed fix that.
Did you see the dark crystal?
Yes.
I love that shit.
And one of my favorite movies,
good movies and that's another movie.
I Bet Ari would say like,
yeah,
you watch it now.
It sucks.
I'm like,
no,
it still,
you remember it as a child.
You grew up with that and maybe that's like a class.
There's a lot of good movies that are still good.
I think these McMahon,
I don't keep meaning to go back to this hippy shit,
but I guess I will for the rest of my life.
I swear man.
I think these movies all came because people were taking acid and mushrooms and
like tripping out and like,
and really going for it.
I think that's what those movies came from is that is a psychedelic,
uh,
bringing something back from the psychedelic universe and then using art as the
kind clothes that you drape around this like,
um,
hyper dimensional form.
I think that's the fucking job,
man.
You go out into that place and you try to bring back the crazy shit that you
catch there.
It's like hunting trips and the like,
um,
alternate dimensions.
But instead of catching animals,
you're catching thoughts and you're bringing them back and then you're trying to
bring them to life by putting them in some form,
pouring them into the mold of your music,
your movie,
your book,
whatever the thing is.
Like what I'm Alex Grey does for example.
Yeah.
Really does that,
he's better than anybody of capturing that dimension and bring it back to
reality.
Yeah.
He's who he is.
What a beautiful guy.
That guy is to like hanging out with him was so intense.
It's just so,
so crackling with like positivity and love and no matter what I was shit on,
he would find a way to like look at the bright side of it at Asco has shitting
all of the fat people at Disneyland on scooters and he's like talking about how
great it is that Disneyland,
it's like,
Whoa,
homeless,
etc. Or uh,
you know,
uh,
accessible for a wheelchair.
I love people like that.
Do those people are the best.
This Guy Ragu or I'll go,
Marcus,
who I have on my podcast,
he was like,
ah,
helps run the love server member foundation,
which is around his foundation like he has,
if they have a podcast now called mind rolling and it's him and his friend and
these guys,
man,
they're so fucking cool.
And I was on the podcast and we were talking about I'd work myself up into a
real hip.
You either over fucking like,
uh,
people that are dying in war and the drones.
I was really mad and really spewing like,
it's coming from anger and it's like,
these are people,
they're cute.
We're killing.
And like the way they dealt with that blast of negativity was super cool because
it wasn't like you shouldn't be negative.
It was like,
hold on.
Think about how angry you are right now.
Think about the mind state that you're in right now.
Think about where you're at right now.
You have now created a fucking,
um,
a division.
You are no longer in a state of unit,
unit of consciousness.
You've now cut the,
you know,
you've parsed the universe and you have done the exact same thing that causes
war to happen.
The exact same thing that causes comp conflict is this,
um,
the way that the mind tends to create the good guys,
the bad guys,
uh,
the,
the evil forces in the good forces right now we've got al Qaeda used to be the
communists before it was the fucking Communist.
It used to be the fucking a British before was,
you know what I mean?
There's always a,
an ENL or the Nazis paradigm,
right?
That's set up the enemy and the good and the bad
paradox of that game is that you inevitably continue the very fucking thing that
you so dreadfully want to stop.
And um,
that's the problem,
right?
You could see in creating that conflict and attacking,
you automatically create a war and you automatically give someone something to
fight for.
And these people like Alex fucking gray,
Aragu Marcus or Rom das,
that's what they
diverting in making things always pause.
They're trying and that's outcome.
He,
man,
it's amazing.
By the way,
there is no comedy in that.
You've gotta be able to shoot on fat people.
Skaters,
I still need to see that.
South Park,
Joe,
that was all about the scooters.
Yeah,
I do this about a thousand south park's I really need to see still,
but dude,
you know what,
I need to start up your iPhone,
you know?
Yeah.
I need,
what I need to do is a,
just like next trip I go on,
just flow the iPad up with like all the best episodes.
Is there a greatest hits of South Park?
Yeah,
there is,
but the best ones,
just like,
uh,
you could download like the season in the last five even.
I've just forced myself recently to start watching standups,
like watching comedy again and you know,
there's a lot of bad stand up out there,
man.
But I rarely watch comedy these days.
Like on television,
I don't watch sitcoms.
I rarely watch.
That's why I don't watch South Park.
It's like I love South Park,
but when I'm alone,
I'm don't go to comedy.
I almost always go to like science.
I almost always go to the discovery channel Shit or you know,
weird things about volcanoes or oceans or you know,
any biology type shit and then retard stuff like,
you know,
like my my comments.
Yeah.
My comedy isn't like big foot or swamp people.
That's my new show.
Swamp people.
If you think of that,
do you gotta wash swamp people?
Crocodiles,
alligators,
and you can't hunt crocodiles in America.
We're trying to revive them.
Dunkin cause there,
it's important to bring the most ruthless and fucking aggressive lizard.
Bring them back to a healthy breeding population.
So we have to worry about dog downtown in downtown La.
A dog just got snatched off a bridge in Miami,
six foot off the water.
This fucking crocodile jumps up and grabs the dog and pulls it into water for a
death row.
Fucking dog.
A Brador.
I think sac might've made up to suck that video of the guy who puts his hand in
the alligator's.
Now do you see that?
Of course.
Say Crocodile.
Those are crocodiles.
Alligator.
Is it,
I don't know.
Crocodiles are much more aggressive.
What's the difference?
They're bigger,
more aggressive,
more dangerous.
They're there.
It's like the difference between poodle and a pit bull.
You know what's cool though,
man?
The good thing it's,
it's interesting how not all animals learn to swarm.
Like only bees swarm like alligators and crocodiles.
They'll like,
if you throw meat into where they're at,
they'll eat it.
But there's,
there's not like organized swarms of alligators that would change the fucking
game they would have.
They're hungry if they're hungry and something goes in the water.
Like when a Willdabeast or an antelope gets Jack,
they all rip it apart.
They're not like Wolfe's,
they don't hunt,
they can't like they don't stalk animals.
There's not like they have a way better setup.
They hold their breath for hours under water in muddy water.
They just stay put and then they explode out of nowhere when you have to come
and drink,
cause there's only one water waterhole like crocodiles are way better than
walls.
Oh please.
They're in Africa,
they're in Africa where there's a fucking million animals and they all have to
come to this waterhole and this is the end of our friendship.
28 foot long dinosaurs that haven't changed in over 200 million years or
waiting,
holding their for hours.
Oh,
by the way,
they don't have to eat for a year.
Sorry man woes like she is
five.
I didn't realize actually
a
little wolf spirit hat.
What are you [inaudible]
Brian,
pull up the video of a wolf.
Uh,
killing wolves.
Killing a coyote.
Put it on your wig.
Dunkin.
It's pretty fun.
The wig doesn't work.
That gun.
Isn't it funny that liked us a certain amount of shit you could wear like in
your daily life.
They'll allow you to wear,
like that's a costume outside of being dressed up for Halloween.
Like you can wear it to pay.
That is not your fucking hair,
but you can wear it to toupee,
but you can't wear a fake mustache.
What was,
what if you were a big fake mustache and try to go through security.
They'll go,
sir,
you take the Monistat shot please.
You're like,
no,
no.
I,
I'm a,
I'm really insecure about my lack of a mustache.
I used to have a mustache,
but my hair fell out of my upper lip.
So now I have to pay muscle.
That is weird.
You gotta take your hat off when you go through Tsa,
but you don't have to take off your to pay
what have yet.
Yeah.
What if she had a Merkin and uh,
they were like,
there's something showing up in your crotch.
Like,
yeah,
nothing.
It's nothing.
You're like,
what's going on?
Can you please,
uh,
unzip your pants?
You have this giant Jew fro down your crotch because she's just always been
really insecure about not having any pubic hair.
So he just glued just this patch of fucking doing and everything is bone dry.
Your balls are bone dry,
your Dick's bone dry out,
hair on your deck.
I have like stray hairs that are growing out halfway up my dick,
every now and then I got to pluck them out.
He pluck,
pluck them,
rip them right out of the roots.
And My,
my pubes are ridiculous if I let them grow,
that's the fucking jungle down there.
But some dudes,
they don't have that.
So they just,
they have a Marcon and you'd go through security.
Do you think they let you keep that merging now?
You got to strip it.
There's probably a bucket of,
I was probably a dog that will snatch it off bite you,
bite your cock,
you know,
pull that Merck and off you get up.
Obama,
I actually even heard the term Merkin American sweat.
Your tastes.
What?
It's murky.
I think.
Um,
it's like a fake pubic hair beard Bush.
But for what reason?
Hold on.
There's no such thing.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
there is,
there's two things.
Like if you get,
like a lot of girls get their shit lasered off so they want once in a while they
want to have,
you know,
like a Bush and then they also have like,
like strippers or like chicks at one.
But that's not,
that's not what it was here then invented
a long time ago.
It was to combat pubic lice.
Yeah.
People,
uh,
they originally worn by prostitutes after shaving their genitalia then now uses
decorative items in erotic devices or in films.
Yeah.
It was in the 1450s.
There was,
it was,
um,
they,
uh,
women shaved their hair and they wore a Merck in the 14 hundreds,
a combat
pubic lice and prostitutes would wear them to cover up signs of disease such as
syphilis.
So they have a big fucking a wig over the city.
If you're fucking prostitute is wearing a pussy wig,
you should be suspicious.
Do you,
did you,
do you think people went raw dog with prostitutes back then?
Like raw dog,
like a bathroom rug?
You know,
after a while she has an old Merkin on.
It's like a bathroom rug.
It's just all fucking good.
In Hollywood filmmaking,
Merkin's are worn by actors and actresses to prevent inadvertent exposure of the
genitalia during nude or semi nude scenes of American.
We're not worn.
It would be necessary to restrict the shot to exclude the genital area.
Dude,
have you ever heard of the way they shoot sex scenes?
How they bring the boyfriends?
And we already talked about this.
Oh,
and the guy watches watches.
So doesn't that,
isn't that sac?
Listen,
you can't have someone have a fake sex scene with someone that's hot.
They're going to get hard.
You're going to want to,
I had a friend who did a fake sex scene in sub terrible movie and the girl goes,
you can fuck me if you want.
The girl actually said that.
He's like,
I don't think I can like you.
He didn't know what to say,
but he's on top of like fake thrusting into her ass asshole with this flacid
penis.
Can you fucking imagine being like someone's husband and sitting and watching
them get fucked by Bruce Willis?
Oh,
some stark room.
Fuck Blues will us.
How bout like,
yeah,
I don't know.
How about like the rock live was great.
The Rock is just like
giant tattooed chest is sweating into your wife's mouth as he's fake.
Pumping her with her legs over head fucking her in a way you could never
possibly do with your lift frame and your joggers body.
Big giant fucking Samoan tribal tattoos on his roided up chest.
And he just pomp in his giant semi hard cock on the outside of your wife's
pussy.
And you know,
deep inside she just slippery and gliding and she's all,
she wish she would just shove it in.
I don't care if you watch watching and you're sitting there,
um,
is this over?
Have you gotten enough takes of this is this,
is this,
are we done here?
Are we done here plus
the society?
Nef what if it was Louie Anderson?
I'm going to get that your wife's Plessy and you have to watch somebody gross.
You know,
Burt fucking job with John Love is sloppy.
Dude eaten a fucking hot dog.
Why bones?
Your wife is sideways glances.
Got To pick your,
his gut up like an under hook,
like a deep,
like a chimp.
Remember those chimps in a buckets where they would have that?
Uh,
that would be like how their paws would connect.
You would play that game with a plastic champs.
We,
he's gotta take his hand and sort of that position to just suck up the gut and
pull it up.
So is short.
Semi hard penis can even get inside your woman stink wafting out of that flap is
like a homeless dude just took off his boot.
Just like
just a combination of the La River after a flood.
These shit rolling water and fucking,
what is it?
What is,
what is a water tap and water now?
What is it?
Water.
When it's stagnant,
stagnant water and shit and old loads.
Oh,
loads in there.
Just the old briny old fucking loads and his come comes out like snot.
When you have the flu,
just yellow,
you know,
you blow your nose when you have the flu and it comes out all yellow.
And that's how it was.
Loads look like the death sneeze of someone with malaria.
It's like your class needs inside of a Boston cream donut.
That custard.
Ah Fuck.
Ah,
yes.
It's not as smooth and delicious looking.
Yeah.
A little congealed little uh,
cottage cheesy and it burns and it burns.
Yeah,
it stings.
And it stings your eyes too.
You have to run to the bathroom.
And if you get it on your eyes,
she'll start crying.
It's like fumes coming up from an old onion.
I was talking to a friend of mine the other day and I didn't tell him this
because his breath was so bad.
I literally thought he shit himself and I didn't know how to,
I just decided I was too high to,
to uh,
to break it down.
And he was sober and I was like,
oh my God,
I can't talk to you.
And it's so true.
Like people who have shitty breath want to tell you these fucking long stupid
stories.
And he wanted to tell me this long story and it was just like,
like prisoners had been farting in his mouth
because it was just like,
like he'd held his mouth open and every fucking prisoner and cell block d just
farted.
In his mind.
It was so bad.
I literally thought he shit his pants.
It was horrible.
Not me,
is it?
No,
I'm saying,
yeah,
I would tell you that was weird.
Civilian,
but it's weird.
Smoker,
like bad breath is almost like a demonic force that possesses people and compel
them to tell the longest,
most boring stories.
It is weird how people with bad breath want to tell your fucking stories.
What is it?
It's a strange thing,
but it's weird of Pew.
I want people to tell me about my bad breath.
If I have bad breath,
please tell me.
Because I know I have it.
Especially if I do like a long show,
you know,
like you do us a show and you're talking for an hour and a half and breathless.
Be Gross.
Yeah.
You're not drinking any,
want me to drink like a little water here and there,
but you know,
like refreshing your mouth.
It's like,
ah,
bad,
bad stomach acids.
Bad,
bad,
bad.
It's probably disgusting.
Tell me.
But I wouldn't tell him.
You know why?
Because some people can handle it.
Some people get all butthurt remember when he went through that brief phase
where you were like,
I'm not wearing deodorant.
It's the smell of a man and you are going everywhere.
Sticking with this muscle.
Well,
I thought that,
uh,
first of all,
deodorant,
um,
I thought it was bad for you and it is bad,
but I decided that if you get cancer from deodorant,
you're a fucking pussy.
That's what I think.
It's how I feel.
Uh,
I,
yeah,
I stopped wearing deodorant for a little while,
just wash myself.
I'm totally into funky and I eat too much meat.
Man,
I'm too much of a predator.
So you smell my armpit.
Do you think that,
like that's why a deer run from you,
by the way,
do you think if you only,
like if you lived on some kind of like Forrest St Diet and you only ate,
like you would smell different tiny
and fucking flowers and you are,
you know,
like you think you'd stop stinking
Oh yeah.
100%.
Yeah.
Part of what you're smelling is like uric acid and all sorts of different shit
that comes through your pores that comes directly.
As a result,
a lot of the smells come directly a result of eating meat.
In fact,
um,
that's one of the things that deer freak out about when,
when d or are,
then they catch you in their nose and they run away.
That's like when the runaway,
the quickest when we were hunting,
when the wind would come off of you and go towards the deer and they would go,
I'm getting the fuck out of here.
There was no mistake in their mind that you were a predator.
He smelled like a meat eater.
That's a,
I think there's a,
there's a,
there's a smell like vegans have very different smell than,
than people who eat a lot of meat.
If you eat like a lot of steak and burgers and shit,
he definitely develop a different school.
It's true.
Yeah.
100% man.
You know your,
your,
your shit smells different.
Jesus Christ.
When I,
when I drank nothing but kale shakes for a couple of days,
my shit doesn't smell bad at all.
It goes right through me.
It smells like pineapples and I flush this giant Green Pineapple smoothie out of
my ass,
but it doesn't smell bad at all.
You're a,
when you're eating a lot of meat,
man,
you're breaking down a lot of shit.
Look,
man,
I'll tell you the recipe for some pretty awful dumped if you want to know
out there.
Yeah.
Fucking it got mind to.
Should share.
Let's see.
Make a cookbook.
Cookbook
Oysters,
oysters,
oysters.
Will Oysters.
Think about what that is.
Oysters,
they're like the phlegm of the ocean.
It's like they're just like these already mucusy things like oysters destroy.
Destroy me.
I can't do it anymore.
Starbucks destroys me one of these coffees every time.
I'm like halfway through it.
I just have to run.
It's a colon cleaner.
Yeah.
I have to go again on my thing.
The the,
no,
there's nothing like the Kale shake though for cleaning the colon out.
Kale shakes were ridiculous.
Like you can't even hold it in.
Have you ever gotten a colonic?
No.
Hold.
It hurts.
Awesome though.
I've also that it's not good for you.
I've heard conflicting things.
Pam Tell it's good for you.
It's not good.
What did you dependent on her side?
I said it's bullshit.
[inaudible] see the problem with Penn and teller as Penn and teller also said
that yoga is bullshit.
Yoga is not bullshit.
They're yoga gets you high.
Okay.
And the only reason why anybody would say that yoga is bullshit is because
they're out of shape and they're not.
And we didn't get their body on this podcast.
Yeah,
they're not unshaved.
They're not in tune with their body and they don't understand that you are
releasing tension and you're creating a different state of consciousness.
When you do yoga,
yoga definitely gets you high.
There's no question about it.
And anybody who says it doesn't,
you're,
you're too out of shape to appreciate it.
That's all it is.
I've,
I've had like real legitimate,
like life changing experiences after yoga where if we really sat down and you
know,
when I say life changing,
I mean like in degrees left right forward,
you know,
like there's like certain times where I've had experiences in my life that were
literally life changing because I sat down and that extra inspiration that I got
from that moment,
that extra positivity,
extra clarity that I got moved me in a percentage of a point in one direction.
And it's almost always towards the good.
I've had that from Yoga,
no question about it.
And it's not just because I chose to have it.
It's also because those techniques of all that stretching and all those,
those,
all those things release tension from the body and the way your body carries
around tension is directly affects the way your mind works directly,
directly affects how you interact with people.
Like true yoga people,
the real yoga people.
Fascinating to be around men that really cool and calm.
And there was this dude from South Africa,
he's take yoga with,
he was so real,
man.
He was still the real deal.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those fake yoga guys that try to like fuck chicks and you know,
they try to like be fake spiritual and they sing like Indian songs.
You know,
that they memorize just to fucking impress people with their,
their,
their Hindu street cred.
You know what I mean?
You know that
kind of fake there.
I've seen them giving massages at rave.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
With their dirty Birkenstocks on and you know saying Namaz Day get out of here
bitch,
don't you know mouse may you,
you it
bitch cause the people in what you're up to.
The people who really practice that shit man,
they don't,
they're,
they don't act like that at all.
There's none of it's there.
It's a whole different fucking animal to the point where it can be shocking
because you kind of expect people to be a certain way.
This is a funny thing.
This is like one of the fun thought experiment you can do is right now,
maybe you don't,
but right now and a lot of people's minds,
they already have this idea of what an enlightened person should act like.
You already have that idea.
Here's what they might be like.
Your mind will try to create an idea of what enlightenment looks like and that
idea is always wrong.
It's never like that at all.
This is that saying when you meet,
if you meet the Buddha on the road,
kill him.
That's the idea,
which is like anything in your mind that's kind of defining the way you think
and advanced person should be,
creates a real big problem.
Uh,
because you'll start pretending to be that way.
You know,
you start putting on a costume or show.
But yeah,
most of those folks you run into are the real deal man.
They just like,
they're just totally in the fucking moment.
I'll go with anything.
It's really hard to be the real deal.
Real Madrid,
the real into the real world known to rule.
You say world world,
world.
No,
you just don't want to say the world's the best thing in the world.
World.
World,
world.
He doesn't say world.
He says rural world were w r o l d world world.
There you go.
White Castles.
Awesome.
It's really the best place in the world.
Please shut the fuck up.
He's changed from uh,
supporting all the garden.
Now he's chewing change to white castle.
Wow.
That ain't shit.
It's fucking good.
Yeah.
It'd be really drunk.
It's delicious.
Great dry drunk people a meet in the future.
I may make my own white castle vets me red cast for Los Angeles.
That's why we need is Fuddruckers.
Yeah.
Back us up and you get those fucking ostrich burgers.
Do you ever get a raw or rare rather ostrich burger at Fuddruckers now?
Oh God damn son.
That shit is
good.
We can have that red castle.
Yeah.
Ostriches or cons to their birds and birds are dinosaurs and all dinosaurs can
go fuck themselves.
This shit out of an ostrich.
I'll eat the shit out of an ostrich.
I will come Maura and ostriches his neck and kill it and eat the shit out of it.
When I was living in Asheville,
their necks are perfect for strangling when I was living.
That's what I bet you can't even get in them though.
But they're next is go right with it there.
I bet.
I bet they can peck the fuck out of right back your Dick.
Why turn your head?
I used to be so poor when I was living in Asheville that I would go to fid
rockers and order a bond and just like eat a lettuce and the tomatoes and the
onions from the fucking do your hammer,
her barbies.
Yet everything you can make a cheap meal and cheese sandwich out of relish and
people's making shitty salad bread.
Yeah.
Incredible.
Okay.
Asheville,
North Carolina is one of the last great spots on earth.
Yeah.
It's almost didn't want to tell people about it.
When we got back,
we were wandering and walking around on the streets.
I was like,
this is one of those places where you could walk around the streets and it's
small.
It's a small town,
but it had all these bars.
You can walk from bar to bar and people were friendly.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Whoa,
Duncan,
this is a crazy place.
We're in like one of the last great places on earth.
Yep.
Asheville North Carolina is one of the last great places on earth.
We walked to a Kava bar.
Okay.
There's bars everywhere and nice people and that.
Sure.
There was a few drum circles and there's a few fucking hippies sitting on the
ground and the sidewalk.
There's a little of that.
I'm going to just fucking say this and I know,
forgive me for saying it,
but Trump's circles are fun.
This fucking go to one.
It's fun.
You get to bang on a drum.
It's like awesome.
Never smell good though.
No,
no one's ever accused of drum circle of smelling gray,
but they're fucking fun.
They're fun.
Do you like the smell of sage?
No.
It's the worst smell ever,
right?
I don't like that smell.
It's horrible.
Yeah.
Sages smells good when you're walking through it.
When you're outside,
you can't escape it.
It's horrible.
When it's on fire.
That's when they burned sage spirits and shit.
When I was a kid,
my mom burned sage in my room cause she thought I'd summon a demon.
We know Salvia sage.
Salvia have enormous,
that's why I thought it's more like self here that the other day I was like,
that's like flashbacks.
Salvia.
I don't know if that sage is psychoactive.
Hmm.
I should find out because if it's true,
you can just find sages,
smoke it.
Yeah.
I went to the day of the dead at the Hollywood forever cemetery.
When was that?
A Friday and it was the worst experience ever.
It was so crowded.
There was one point you couldn't move any direction.
I just wanted to cry and run,
but are you ever doing any more comedy shows or you think,
ah,
I don't know.
Um,
I don't know what's going to happen with that.
I'm so busy right now.
I don't have time to do it.
That shit was always fun.
Yeah.
Sage is Salvia.
There's no crazy,
no wonder I was having flashbacks and one of the several genera commonly,
how do you say?
What is that genre,
but it is that action now?
No,
no.
Generra genetics or something about genetics.
Yeah,
it's a body term.
Several Generra,
whatever commonly referred to as sage.
Let's,
let's look puking.
Give our listeners to answer what is,
look it up in the dictionary.
I love that.
Highlight.
It look it up.
The Niche Canary Jenise yeah,
that's right.
I thought it was that principal taxonomic category that ranks above species and
below family.
Hmm.
And is denoted by a capitalized Latin name for Eg.
Leo.
Okay.
So,
um,
it's uh,
it's,
it's one of the,
uh,
types of,
of sage.
That's what Salvia divinorum is.
It's one of the several different kinds of sage.
Huh.
So I don't know how much of that shit that you walk into when you're wandering
through the woods.
It's step over sage brush.
I want how much of that can you light on fire and see Jesus?
Probably.
I bet a lot of it,
you know.
I bet.
I bet it's pretty common.
Let's see.
How common is Salvey in the wild?
Let's look up that.
Is that target?
Yeah.
You'd get at a target.
Shut up.
Yeah.
They fell Salvia at fucking salary plans.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
They sell,
they sell fucking Payoti.
Ooh,
what?
Yeah.
They sell the fucking cactus man,
San Pedro cactus.
You can buy at any home depot.
You take that San Pedro cactus and make fucking payoti allegedly of no.
Yes,
you can wait.
You could also take the fucking morning glory seeds and smash them up and cook
them and make a very potent psychoactive.
Similar to LSD.
Lsa,
I believe is what a job.
As a matter of fact,
they've actually taken steps to make the seeds a non psychoactive.
They like poison these socks.
You make it so it's like,
well,
upset your stomach.
Yeah.
Hawaiian Rosewood too.
That's another one,
not mag.
That's another one to Tura devils.
Gypsum.
See,
that's another one.
Huge spool spoon.
The cinnamon is supposed to make you trip.
Yeah.
In some parts of the world,
particularly in northern Mexico and southwestern United States like we were low
Lee live bitches.
Salvia divinorum grows wild.
It's fucking wild out here,
man.
That's nuts.
It's wild right here.
Oh boy.
I don't like Salvia.
You don't?
I do not like don't do it anymore.
Why?
What's going or what that buzz.
You can't handle it.
Yeah,
I guess if you want to say it like that,
I just don't like the feeling.
It's like,
it's like it's a,
it's not a great high,
it's not an exact dirty,
dirty half.
Feels like a damaged too.
It just doesn't work.
It just after
you get done doing it,
you're sweating your ass off.
Like your body goes from like,
like zero to a hundred.
Your heart beats going so bad,
you just drenched in sweat.
You have that dirty like fucking like my brain feels fucked up feeling and it's
just a gross feeling.
Like almost like a,
like a sinus hangover or something makes us a drug that was sh shamonic drug.
It's like,
it's like more in the line of like,
I don't know,
but I've read that like it began is not a pleasant high.
It's like,
it's meant to be used as a kind of in accordance with like a sham and,
or someone who knows what they're doing to like create some spiritual effect.
It's not meant so that you can fucking pass out in front of Mario brothers and
your trailer.
Like,
you know,
it's not,
it's not the way people use it now as they get,
you know,
they fucking smoke that shit with the Xbox playing in the background and like
a baby sleeping in the other room.
It's,
I don't think it's that kind of drug.
It's not one of the pleasant drugs.
Like there are a psychedelics that if you take low doses definitely can be
social lubricants and can be fun for partying,
but Salvia doesn't feel like that at all.
Yeah,
well people that take it to make videos of them taking it certainly support
that.
Yeah.
Little those videos of people like Brian has a few of them out there and the one
with Ari freaking out,
whether they already did it in front of them and Ari did it in this area is one
of my favorite stories of Salvia.
Ari did it and lived another life for months.
He made friends,
he had relationships,
he lived life in this artificial world for months and then was snapped back to
reality when it,
when it's sobered up and he said he'll never forget it.
He said it was,
it was really weird listening to him describe it.
It's like I had a whole nother life from month.
Yes.
I did it with Bobby Lee and he said he felt like he was on a pirate ship.
Covered in spiders.
It Brian,
you know,
I don't know.
I think you're supposed to let these lasers hit you in the eyeball.
Huh?
These are club lasers,
so they're okay.
The club,
when you go blind,
the club,
it's fine.
Just posted there.
Yeah,
there they are.
Okay.
Though,
then hit your nightclubs and stuff like that.
Oh,
okay.
What happens with the hit your eyeballs?
Nothin.
You know I,
I read this thing where they said that you were supposed to not wear sunglasses
and that you should allow a certain amount of sunlight to hit your eyes because
it was essential nutrients,
nutrients,
nutrients that you get from sunlight.
Just like you get nutrients from sunlight and vitamin D,
but also you get nutrients that help your vision.
I never wear sunglasses.
I'm wearing them now just for Halloween,
but I never wear them to the point where I think I probably fucked my eyes up a
little bit from not wearing well they say if you go like skiing or something,
you know,
like snow blindness.
Callen knows a guy who went snow blind.
Literally he went blind.
You went to climb k two and a,
the snow was so bright,
he didn't have sunglasses on there for one day.
One of his eyes went,
that sucks.
That sucks.
I got,
yeah,
I got sunburn on my eyeball because it rained.
I was in myrtle beach and it rained on the uh,
table and the table was glass
and then I hung out and drank on the table for a few hours in the reflection off
the water on the glass table,
I guess like,
like magnified the,
the raise or whatever.
And for three days I couldn't see,
like I couldn't open my eyes.
My eyes were watering and earning.
I just had to sit there and just like close my eyes at myrtle beach for three
days.
If you had to pick a sense to lose.
I wouldn't.
Let's not do this.
What be,
I don't like to do that honey booboo.
His mom or honey booboo.
Yeah.
I like Connie boob was mom cause she's probably probably can't get pregnant
anymore.
You,
you would pick honey booboo.
His mom over being able to see the,
I'm not talking about,
you know is honey booboo his mom or honey booboo.
Yeah,
that's the,
it's like we're not going to play.
You don't want to play that game?
No,
it's stupid.
It's negative
like a lot of people.
Native land loss.
Just talk.
Start talking about loss.
What'd rather you lose your feet to lose your ooo stupid.
There's other things to think by the way.
That's an easy answer.
Yeah,
it is easy.
Okay.
Cause they make fake feet but fake dicks don't feel shit.
Yeah,
right.
Is that what it is now?
Mass Day.
I just enjoyed some amazing vegan salad.
[inaudible]
no mustache.
Duncan Trussell.
Why are you wearing a wool fat?
This fucking hat.
Yeah.
Why are you wearing?
Why do I have to ask why I'm wearing
what's the most amazing have here on earth?
Where'd you get it?
I got it in fucking Nevada city.
Northern California.
Like the very,
yeah,
like with the Emerald Triangle.
One of my friends got a,
uh,
legal marijuana farm up.
There is no such thing federally and whatever fund.
Matter of fact,
I'm going to have to stop smoking marijuana because I want to pursue,
uh,
my,
hunting obsession,
my new hunting obsession.
So I'm gonna quit pot.
If you guys were both single,
would you fuck this girl?
Uh,
who wouldn't?
Okay.
Cause that's the lady boy
that was like the easiest trap is that girl that's alive.
Thank God I didn't think about it for a second.
I don't have to listen to her talk.
I'd probably be able to smell him.
No,
I'd probably go smell her.
Know that she was
boy Brody just recently on a podcast came out and saying that he went to a
overseas for a movie Bangkok and tested out a lady.
Boy,
what do you think?
He's,
he's so,
he's now thinks he's 10% gait.
He doesn't want to pursue that.
He just wanted to see if he was or not.
What happened in the,
how did he,
what did,
how did they fuck what happened?
Was he on top?
No,
I guess it was just made me a blow job.
Oh boy.
Wow.
You know,
you can get gonorrhea from mouse contact.
300,000 cases of gonorrhea in 2000 did you recently get concrete?
No.
I'm just telling you.
I'm just saying don't let dudes who dress up like girls and give out blow jobs.
Suck your Dick because their mouth ain't too picky.
That's what I'm trying to,
you should do publicly.
Everyone now who buys a gun must fill out
the ATF form four,
four,
seven three which asks,
are you an unlawful user of or addicted to marijuana or any depressant,
stimulant,
narcotic,
drug,
or any other controlled substance?
Well,
that's,
that's an amazing question.
First of all,
because you can,
you can answer.
No,
I'm not because I'm not an unlawful user because I'm a medical marijuana user
and the state of California where I had a doctor's prescription for it.
So no,
that's done all lot.
But it's not true federally.
And then it's to say are you addicted to marijuana or any depressant stimulant.
What about coffee?
Like they could like legally they could bring you to jail if you drink coffee
every day.
That's right.
This is how stupid this law is.
Narcotic drug or any other controlled substance.
That's fascinating man.
All you were an unlawful user of and what does that mean?
A user of in the past tense or user of currently cause like currently I'm not
doing anything.
I'm not smart.
I'm not doing anything right now.
So I could say I could write down that report.
No,
because currently I'm not right.
But like what does that mean?
Like user like it.
How does that fit into your lifestyle?
Like do do you,
do you have like PR every day you have to smoke a joint.
Just like everyday you have to take your fucking thyroid medication.
No.
Like what kind of a weird ass question is that?
What kind of a weird open end questions that and that can keep you from having a
gun.
I just got my shit renewed yesterday.
Look,
oh stone.
It wasn't my pitcher.
You can see my eyes.
You look barbecued son.
Yeah.
Isn't that fascinating,
man?
Like are you an unlawful user of or addicted to?
First of all,
the idea that you're addicted to marijuana.
That's like saying,
are you addicted to washing your hands?
Because it's the same people that get addicted to marijuana or addicted to
anything and you just,
but that's something that an optimistic thing to put on your form because you're
just naively assuming that anyone's going to answer that question.
Honestly.
No,
no.
What they're doing is they're making it so that anybody runs,
uh,
who runs a medical marijuana plant,
can't arm themselves.
You know,
if you have a fucking farm and you're growing medical marijuana and the
government comes in to take you,
they can also bust you for usually [inaudible] for having these guns illegally
and for lying on these federal forms,
which is electric like perjury.
Ah,
these fucking Goblins,
man,
it's the worst.
It's unbelievable.
I can work that pass through.
You know,
this,
this a second.
You know,
the,
the second amendment is very important part of anybody who wants to hunt their
own food and be able to protect themselves from criminals,
be able to,
uh,
you know,
protect themselves from predators.
If you live in like a rural community,
if you live like if you live in Montana and you're,
you're living out in the woods like that,
that show mountain men,
these motherfuckers,
they need guns to shoot off bears.
They have bears that they need to shoot at.
I mean,
if you don't,
the bear comes in each
you,
I mean to say that they can't have bears because they also have arthritis that
medical marijuana cures.
Well,
look,
here's the other fucking thing.
By the way,
fuck the reason.
God dammit.
Here's another fun thing you can do.
Shoot shooting guns.
It just fucking fun.
It's fun to shoot bottles.
It's fun to shoot targets.
It's fun to shoot a fire,
a gun.
It's just a blast.
Like there shouldn't,
we should.
The whole point is it's not about reason.
It's like you get to have a gun in this country.
If you want to have a fucking gun.
It shouldn't be based on whether or not you smoke something that grows out of
the ground.
Meanwhile,
you can have like hunter s Thompson had a fucking bar.
It is shooting range,
a bar.
Have you ever seen that?
A full fucking bar with a butler.
You can have that.
Yeah,
but you can't smoke pot and shoot.
That's right.
Yes.
Yeah.
You could be.
You got a prescription for Oxycontin as long as it's legal.
As long as it's legal,
you don't have that problem.
Any Person Buhr assistant director Arthur Herbert rights in the open letter to
all gun sellers.
Yes.
Any person who uses or is addicted to marijuana,
regardless of whether his or her state has passed legislation authorizing
marijuana used for medicinal purposes is prohibited by federal law from
possessing firearms or ammunition.
That shit makes me want to join the NRA.
It really does.
The I am going to,
I think I am.
I think the NRA was fucking dead,
right?
I think they all this time that the NRA has been trying to stop the government
from taking away gun rights.
Now I understand it now.
I get it all this time I thought it was like,
wow,
these crazy gun nuts.
They really want to have machine guns.
Hey,
they really want to have assault rifles.
No,
they just don't want to have these people telling you what you can and can't
have.
It's simple man.
It's a simple fucking right.
It's obvious.
It's to the ATF,
uh,
or the National Rifle Association is in commenting on it.
So as the national rifle association with frequently but with which frequency?
Frequently butts heads with the ATF has not put out a statement on the letter
and a spokesperson there did not return calls for comment.
Oh,
spokesman for rocky mountain gun owners was also silent.
Well,
you know,
that's a,
that's,
that's really sad.
That's,
it's a really sad thing because that's just the pressure from pharmaceutical
companies that are trying to make sure that medical marijuana doesn't spill off
into some sort of,
uh,
decriminalization event nationwide and,
you know,
to stop it in its place.
They've they,
they started,
it started out in Montana and a,
the reason why it's in Montana is because,
have you ever been to Montana?
A huge percentage of the people in Montana Hunt when we were in Montana,
um,
everywhere we drove people where there was like signs that said welcome hunters,
like in bars and restaurants to welcome hunters.
It's a lot of fucking people hunting up there and there's also a lot of people
out there that liked to get high,
so they decided to kill the medical marijuana community there by making it so
that if you are illegal registered medical marijuana patient,
you can't own a firearm.
Well fucking pigs.
Unbaked fucking believably gross man.
It's really disgusting.
It said,
I'm Jeff door.
Sure.
A spokesperson,
a spokesman for the US attorney's office in Colorado said the decision whether
to prosecute someone would be made on a case by case basis.
That's basically saying they have you by the balls.
There don't appear to be any cases in Colorado where people have been prosecuted
for illegally owning guns because they are medical marijuana patients because
there's so many medical marijuana patients who have guns in Colorado.
You,
you've just made felons out of you know,
a million people and that's not exaggeration.
The medical marijuana community in Colorado is fucking amazing,
isn't it?
Isn't it basically a slippery slope though?
Like the moment you ask as a government say that people can't consume a plant
that has,
you can't overdose on the moment you're making laws like that,
isn't it kind of a slippery slope where you can't expect there to be other
logical laws following that?
I mean,
isn't the thing like of like what they're doing is obviously wrong and that
seems to be part of what they do.
The federal government makes shitty laws that have no basis in actual reality
and are just based on whatever their weird power agenda is.
It's that,
but I think it's also them.
It's a death row.
They're exposing their belly.
I think they're,
they're,
they're showing how fucking stupid their system really is.
That they're actually,
they're creating a law that's going to make people angry and furious and the
wrong people gun owners because gun over gun owners and hunters for some of the
most organized motherfuckers.
You know,
it's really interesting how these,
um,
fish and game departments are entirely funded.
The conservation efforts are entirely funded by hunters.
Hunters and hunting and gun owners are the ones who organize like one of the
best run departments in the entire country is the,
the,
the different states,
fish and game departments.
They're incredibly efficient at managing game populations,
et setting tag limits at,
at it,
managing the number of livestock or wildlife rather wildlife stock like men and
females.
And they do all these surveys and tests.
They're incredibly efficient because it's all based on people actually care
about the environment who actually go out and hunt these wild animals.
So you're going,
you're going,
you're going to get them against you.
You know,
and this is supposed to be,
the government is supposed to be the people that are looking out for you.
There's no reason to pass this.
There's no fucking reason.
They're just making shit more complicated and making government deeper,
creating more fucking problems,
creating more conti scenarios where you're going to lock someone in jail because
they liked to smoke weed and I like to hunt.
You dummies.
Yep.
Ps,
all this makes me want to do is get baked and go shoot a gun.
Almost makes me want to do is go to Canada.
I told it makes me want to do it makes me want to run away from these stupid
fucking laws.
These are dumb.
The idea that you could put yourself in jeopardy,
that you could possibly get locked in a cage and not be able to see your family
for an extended period of time because you did something that you wanted to do
that didn't hurt anybody.
It's fucking crazy and believe me,
if you were stoned and you had a gun,
you'd be careful as fuck.
Oh my God.
You'd be so goddamn paranoid or I think you would.
You might be an idiot though.
You might just fuck it,
dude.
Just start shooting things.
Man.
When I,
when I grew up around guns,
nothing is like growing up around guns makes you so safe with guns.
Like somewhat since I was like can remember my dad liked me cause kids like
little boys I fake gun and my dad would like even with a fake guns he would like
teach us like never point this in somebody,
here's how you handle a weapon.
And then when then of course you would like taught us to shoot and it was like
the way how strict and stern he was with weapons.
Like I'll never forget that.
I'm so fucking careful when I get around guns because he like raised me in the
right way.
And that came from being only people who haven't been around.
Guns are afraid of guns.
Yeah.
You know like when your kids find guns in your house and if your kids are raised
and taught what a gun is and what's important and why it's dangerous,
they're going to be okay because they're there.
They're used to being around them anyway.
You know what the saddest,
put the safety on.
You know,
when the safety's off you note and not to fucking pointed at anyone
bullet in the chamber,
you know,
all those things.
And also,
by the way,
if you've got fucking guns,
the responsible thing is you have a goddamn gun safe.
You put your fucking guns in a safe,
you don't leave them around.
Yeah.
Period.
It's um,
it's,
it's really unfortunate when the government has to pass laws like this.
They don't have to,
but when they try to pass laws like this to further some other agenda,
it's the,
the,
the agenda against medical marijuana is what it is.
It's that simple.
It's trying to slow the medical marijuana movement.
And so they involve guns and I,
I think it's a mistake.
It's fucking disgusting.
Did you see that editorial article CNN just put out on a legal why we should
legalize marijuana?
Yes,
I did see.
So cool.
It's amazing.
Well,
meanwhile,
still illegal.
Meanwhile,
people are getting arrested every 37 seconds.
Is that the statistics?
39 37 30 Jesus,
man.
Yeah.
In this country,
by the way.
Yeah.
That's fucking stupid.
Stupid.
It's a waste of Goddamn time and it's become a business in and of itself.
That's the real issue.
The real issue is that it's become a fucking business.
The business of arresting people and keeping people in jail.
The business of closing down medical marijuana farms and catching Mexican drug
runners living in the,
uh,
northern California mountains,
and they have giant,
like wild fucking these huge setups out there where they have the shit growing
wild,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
So brains up there constantly,
you could just start planting it.
Yeah.
And then they harvest it all,
but they have these dudes living up there and camps.
They have a,
they even have a god or a a saint that they pray to that narcos on their fucking
guns.
Yeah.
They have like pictures of the sky,
but is the narco saints these got it name.
Hold on,
I'll find out.
What is working name is powerful.
Google.
Good.
Go.
Hasemyer.
Gugu look at it.
The fuck was de Souza.
Malverde sometimes known as the generous band at the angel of the poor or the
narcan bandits.
Robin had.
Isn't that amazing?
Do you know what Robin Hood was initially about?
Now the king owned land.
You couldn't hunt the Kingsland.
Robin Hood would hunt the land and take the deer and a and give it to the poor.
That's what the robbing from the rich and feeding the poor was none.
Amazing.
Yeah.
I thought it was about money.
I,
we started out with that,
start out with poaching.
Poaching the king's deer.
The king's mother,
dear man.
The king's always got deer.
Yeah.
Well apparently the difference between the way wildlife is run in American
wildlife was run in the European world and that was one of the things that made
the United States so great when people came here from Europe,
was that in Europe?
Uh,
all land and hunting is all owned by royalty and rich people.
Yeah.
And so there's no private,
there is no public hunting.
It's all on private land.
Whereas in America,
the wildlife is all the,
the people's,
like even on public or even on private land,
like say if you own private land,
you still can't shoot everything that's on that land.
You have to have like a tag for the deer,
right?
You have to kill,
you know,
only a certain amount of them according to how much population you have in the
area.
And that was a,
what was that made like?
These Daniel Boone characters that came here from,
from a European background,
so happy that they could live this sort of a different life where they're
running around just hunting whenever they want it to and be able to provide for
their family,
which you couldn't do in,
in Europe.
You literally couldn't go out and hunt food unless you went to a private land
preserve.
It's still a lot of countries in Scotland is still like that can,
I can't just go there.
I have to go to these private places.
It's amazing,
man.
It's incredible.
The different things that powerful people will do cunt.
Yeah.
Fix the world.
Dunkin.
I'm working on Ken,
you're the king.
Fix the world.
How you do it?
How do I fix the world?
Yes.
Well,
I mean obviously we start paying teachers the amount that we paid doctors,
creating a competitive environment and doctors getting fucked over man.
Well,
let's see.
Okay,
so we pay teachers a fuck load of money so that it becomes what you pay actors.
Yeah,
that's it.
Imagine that.
That's it.
And you have like Academy Awards for the best teachers.
So teachers become the celebrities.
Yeah.
Fucking make it so that the,
it's the most competitive energy industry to get in.
So the people who become teachers or these fucking super genius,
brilliant people who start really teaching kids about how incredible and
beautiful the universe is,
teach them about fucking Feinman teach them how to like a synthesize LSD
boom that you do that man
behavior as labeled in the Patriot Act.
What you just said,
what
teaching them about Feinman no,
the other part.
Ah,
well fuck them dude.
Everybody fuck them,
dude.
No,
that's the problem man.
You fucking start with the kids.
Get them educated,
get them re excited about life.
Get them to understand that we exist in a beautiful,
juicy,
vibrant world.
And that your brain is an owl chemical laboratory which can produce thoughts,
which if you put those thoughts into action,
can transform your entire planet in the same way that the invention of
electricity or the varieties of technologies that have come from the mind have
shifted our planet.
Uh,
completely and perhaps perpetually you teach kids that your mind is a fucking,
is the laboratory from which every single innovation that is affected your
species has come.
You share the same brain that Einstein had fine Manhattan,
Buddha had you have that computer.
Here's some,
here's different operating systems that you can decide on.
You teach them about yoga.
You teach them about health,
you get them fucking high when they're ready.
Initiatory rituals,
you bring them into a visceral experience of the beauty of life.
Instead of putting them in little fucking boxes,
making them sit at uncomfortable seats and listened to underpaid,
angry people.
Not all of them.
Some teachers don't give a fuck and they're beautiful people,
but some of them are like not being treated with any kind of respect.
And the end result is there's speed.
You're there,
they're phoning it in,
you know,
and so that makes kids,
when they think about reading or books or math or any of it,
they just have this like the same reaction you have when you've gotten a Tequila
hangover and someone offers you tequila because you've been having this shit,
uh,
pumped into you in the absolute wrong way.
We can't educate kids the way we make flog raw by fucking forcing shit down into
their mouse until they're poisoned and sickened by it and hate it because it's
coming from angry,
bitter people.
A lot of the times I can remember certain teachers I had,
man,
there were of course hist angry shit ads and it made me hate the information.
Okay.
But play devil's advocate.
When you look at the,
the possibility of computer simulations and you look at the idea that life is
some sort of computer program,
those people inspired you to not be like them.
Those people inspired you with,
uh,
energy and the motivation and will to,
to move past their paradigm and to see the error of their ways.
And one of the best ways to see the error of someone's ways is to see someone
who's just preaching bullshit,
living a miserable life.
You see it and it's like,
it's,
it's almost more powerful sometimes then a positive image and a,
a positive message.
Some of the reason why I got motivated to do all the things that I did was cause
I was raised shitty.
I'll tell you what's motivated me,
dude.
What's motivated me is running into some really great teachers in my life.
You my friend,
email Amos,
this guy's a fucking amazing musicians that genius different have different
college professors.
The professor who convinced me to go to fucking India,
like really brilliant people.
I agree with that.
You've done the same thing to me as I have all of my,
uh,
my,
my friends.
Yeah.
But I also think that the people that would try to stop me and the people that
are such shitty things to me,
those,
those people just,
they start a fire inside of me that I don't know if it would have been there if
just it was just a positive reaction.
No,
the Yin and the Yang is important
and I am certainly not.
I clearly you're never going to get rid of this fucking that,
that negative element.
But you can be with people who teach what you just said,
what you just said,
which is a kind of like Nietzsche and idea that we need that part of what we
need is a thing to resist.
We need a thing to rise above.
We need a thing that we can get angry at the Mo that motivates us,
but that shit can be taught.
You can teach that to kids.
You can teach that to people.
Like you can show people that you could just bring people these philosophies
that have been developed by super geniuses and let the kids pick,
let them decide.
And you can do it.
Coming from charismatics and coming from performers instead of coming from
people who just want to get fucking home.
So there's like this positive ways to achieve results and there's negative ways
to achieve positive results and the negative reinforcement forces you to rebound
and to,
to push away from that and thus create a positive result.
But it's also possible to create that positive result with correct nurturing and
a real philosophy for life.
A real positive philosophy.
So it's,
it's almost like we are,
we're almost,
we're almost destined to follow a positive.
We,
we have several different options for achieving a positive result,
including being raised badly,
you know,
including being raised by someone who doesn't care about you and forces you to
be a much more loving and caring,
apparent.
You know,
this,
this is a story I really probably piss off a lot of the audience cause it's a
Jesus story,
but I just read it.
Somebody sent me this book of like monks writing essays on the Gospels and
there's this,
and when you hear this,
at first it's like,
come on,
that's so fucking stupid.
But then when you think about it,
it's kind of a cool idea.
But there's this story like Christ is walking through the temple with his
fucking disciples and there's a blind man that he heals.
And um,
they ask him
why was that man blind was,
why was that man born blind?
Is it because of his sins or that now you have to understand this is coming from
a primitive desert philosophy,
sins and all that shit.
But they're saying,
is it because of his Karma or is it because his parents bad Karma?
They're asking like,
what's the reason that this guy is fucked up?
And the response is really brilliant and their response was the guy.
And if you take it literally it's stupid.
But their response was he was,
he's born blind so that that miracle could be worked through him.
So that novelty could come into the universe in the moment that he regained his
sight.
And I think that's a really beautiful fucking idea,
which is that your situation,
whatever your specific situation happens to be,
that as a negative backed into a corner,
dark fucking place.
In one way it's the most awful thing ever.
But in another way there is nothing more fucking beautiful.
Like when you have a friend who's like a desperate,
horrible fucking alcoholic who's life has gone to shit,
who's broke all the time and is almost dying,
and you see him overcome that fucking addiction.
And all of a sudden this guy,
wherever he goes to anyone who's an alcoholic,
is like a living representation of the fact that you don't have to live like
that.
That is fucking powerful.
So your negative state,
whether you're obese,
whether you're a drunk,
whether you're on heroin,
whatever the fucking thing is that you happen to be in because of circumstance
or whatever that has the potential energy,
you can convert that into a living teaching so that everyone around you can see
that you mastered yourself and rose above the darkness.
And the people who are in that dark place,
there'll be inspired by that a million times more than reading the Bhagavad Gita
a thousand times.
Or,
um,
he's seeing something written down because you're the living example of the fact
that life,
human life and the human individuals life can radically transform for the
positive if you focus.
And if you are,
there's some luck in there too.
But,
so the point is,
these negative situations they're given to us is [inaudible] just want to say
given,
but there an opportunity to really show people shit can get better.
That because men,
when I hear something,
you know,
like when you see someone who's a cunt and there yapping about whatever the
fuck,
you know what I mean?
But their wife socks and they're always in drama and they're in a bad
relationship.
You know what it's like,
what are you talking about?
But when you run into an authentically happy person who's utilized principles
and transform their lives,
you fucking listen to that man.
Well,
when you run into people that are doing things also,
you like feel the need to do things.
When you read about someone's inspirational,
you get inspired,
you know,
you,
we,
we draw energy from other examples,
including negative ones.
You'll see a fat person will motivate you to go to the gym.
You'll see some guy in a fucking scooter with his gut hanging over the
handlebars and you'll,
you'll throw the twinkie away,
you know?
Yeah.
We,
we,
we were,
were capable of taking positives from negatives.
Damn right.
We can draw energy from all sources.
It doesn't just have to be like,
uh,
inspirational people.
Certainly you can like the ideal.
Really the idea is whatever the energy is coming into your deposit shifted,
turn it,
transform it,
be the fucking prism that shifts whatever that energy is into like a beautiful
rainbow instead of like a Turd and even one of those pause.
Positive.
Just let it enhance your rainbow.
Yeah,
to enhance your,
your your beautiful vision of the world and pump it up even further and you know
that it's something that like people could say,
oh,
he goes,
talk about that all the time.
I really think you have to,
I think it's something that's a mantra.
I think it's something that needs to be repeated.
It's an ethic that needs to be ingrained in our mentalities and that's why I say
it all the time because I'm also doing it for myself.
I want to,
I want to pump my own version of it up in my own head.
I'm not immune to negative feelings and thoughts.
I'm just a very diligent watcher.
I'm a very diligent guard if my consciousness,
so when I repeat positive things,
it's not that I'm trying to convince myself.
It's a marine forcing these positive traits in my own mind and in the mind of
other people and maybe a little bit,
a bit repetitive sometimes and get get a bit redundant,
but I think we need it.
I really do.
I think you need it yourself.
I think I need it.
I think things society needs it.
I think it's missing.
It's missing from all of our entertainment.
It's missing from Anderson Cooper,
CNN reports.
It's missing from,
it's missing from the fucking that news of all this shit of the day and the
hurricane devastation.
There's missing a,
a broadcast from the,
from from the collective consciousness of broadcast,
from the culture of the world that we can slowly but surely despite all the news
and evidence to the contrary,
slowly but surely all moved towards a more positive state.
This thing you're talking about is that what I think of as the river and the
forest effect.
If you've ever been walking in a forest and suddenly you become aware of the
sound of the river.
It's been there the whole time,
but if you don't,
it's such a subtle sound that blends in with the wind and the sound,
but all of a sudden you hear that light trickling of water running over rocks.
That's what you're talking about.
It's a kind of like metaphysical river that runs through everything and it's
very subtle and it's very easy to forget that it's there
and we got to figure out how to get it to the ATF.
We've got to figure out how to get it to these fucking crazy ass.
The same people that brought you the fast and the furious,
trying to lock you up for having a rifle and a fucking medical marijuana
license.
We've got to get this to the same people that run the federal bank.
They want to pretend that some fucking crazy debt that we have to pay off to.
Hello,
what?
Where's that money?
What does it even mean?
What is your money represent you fucking crazy ass holes with your numbers and
your fucking,
the scroll underneath the,
when you're watching the news and that stock market scroll goes under,
you're like,
what are you sad?
Yeah,
fuck are you doing,
we have to fix it.
Well first fucking here at yourself.
That's the first goddamn sticks.
The people,
goddammit,
fix the conch and then get to the point where the consciousness is evolved so,
so much that it's,
it's,
it's ridiculous to everyone,
including the people that are in charge.
But it,
you know,
and I,
this is another thing we always say,
but we're just talking about this reminds me of it,
man.
It's so easy to forget this shit and it's so easy to like go out into the world
and like everything's Goddamn like rubbing you the wrong way.
Everything's like can seem fucking terrible.
But then when you realize like,
no,
you don't have to be a victim,
you can either get rolled by the wave of phenomena or you can surf on the
fucking top of it.
And when you remember that,
then suddenly when you go out into the world,
the asshole you run into at the fucking gym,
the shitty waiter,
whatever,
the cotton traffic,
these things become little packets of energy that you can use to enhance your
existence and to grow,
but God damn,
it's easy to forget and it's easier to have led them to be rolled.
It's easier to be angry.
It's a form of laziness.
Yeah.
We're an intellectual laziness and physical laziness.
That's one of the things that look,
in order to have a sound body,
you have to have a sound mind.
Sounds like a cliche,
but it's fucking true.
You got to eat healthy and you got to drink a lot of water and you got to get
some fucking exercise and if you don't get some exercise in,
your body's going to betray you.
Your body's going to lie to you.
It's going to give you stress.
It's unnecessary.
It's going to send you signals that you have to deal with.
You need to keep your fucking machine healthy.
Your vehicle for traveling through this dimension is your body.
Keep that bitch healthy.
See,
I see this shit.
This is water.
I drink a liter of this every couple of hours.
I slept like a race horse every five seconds in my pain court.
And folks,
take your vitamin.
Brian's over there with a class of heroin mixed with AIDS.
Yeah,
I flavor my heroin with AIDS.
There's nothing like heroin flavor.
Take off your glasses and show the world your eyes,
Duncan Trussell.
Let them know.
Let them see your soul.
Let them see through the windows of your soul.
They're fun to wear those glasses,
man.
Folks,
as podcast is over,
but can I talk about is shocked.
Yeah,
you can.
I have this show coming up.
I'm going to beat the fun,
fun,
Fun fest this weekend in Austin,
but on the sixth what does that,
it's as bad as festival in Austin.
That happens on the flooring is bad ass from Austin,
but the show please come to this.
It's Fitzgerald's in Houston on the sixth that is a show that I really would
love for you guys to come.
I have one in Dallas,
but it's sold out.
But the one in Houston,
there's still tickets November six at Fitzgerald's.
If you go to my website,
Duncan trussell.com you get tickets there.
We're full fulltime,
Ken.
Thanks Jeff.
Thanks.
Let me plug please anytime.
Man.
This weekend,
uh,
Seattle,
Washington on Saturday night,
the November 3rd at the Moore theater is completely sold out.
Uh,
sorry,
bitches,
but were just awesome.
Um,
Voodoo chicken.
Are you going to make a scheduled appearance?
We've got to contact the Voodoo chicken.
Bryan red bands come in and of course Greg Fitzsimmons will be there as well.
Um,
and by the way,
when I say that we're awesome.
Seattle,
I mean,
you guys too.
all of us together,
it's not just like us.
I wouldn't say like me and Duncan and Brian are awesome.
We're all awesome.
Yeah.
We're all a part of this awesome experience.
A San Francisco Friday night,
November 2nd at the Nob Hill Masonic Center.
Yeah,
I know masonic piece.
I Dunno,
I don't get it.
For me,
it's just a place to perform.
Folks.
I call live.
Nate,
I don't even call live nation.
I have a representative that calls them.
I don't even deal with those people for myself.
You know what I'm saying?
I let somebody else do all the dirty work for me.
That was the only,
it's there's nothing
sinister about this Nob Hill Masonic Center and um,
they'll probably smell like weed in there.
We're going to get our free on
Fuck San Francisco.
It's one of the greatest fucking to the masons.
New added build a place to focus energy.
I used to,
I performed the masonic hall.
You can really fucking blast the beam and those places,
man.
I can really do it well.
It's supposed to be a really cool place.
Um,
and some tickets are still available for that.
Some tickets are also available for,
uh,
the metropolis in Montreal in November 16th.
Are you coming with me?
Duncan Trussell?
Yes.
Montreal.
You're fucking wait.
Yes.
Oh,
can I say one more thing?
I forgot.
I November 7th and eighth.
I'm in New Orleans at the hell.
Yeah.
Fast.
So come to that please.
Oh,
Brian,
my little calendar.
You don't have the 10th,
which is San Diego.
I know Joe Rogan,
uh,
on the,
um,
the Twitter page.
Please put that up because Joey Diaz and I are at the Balboa theatre.
Maybe Brian Red Band too,
if he wants to make,
well,
I went down the 10th.
Oh No.
You're going to be out of town.
You're going to be in the Ohio.
Yeah.
Cool.
I'm with Tom Sager and a date in the,
uh,
November 8th and Cincinnati November 9th.
Those two shows are not selling as fast as the Columbus people.
Yeah.
Which is Columbus now
rung as always,
that we might be looking into buying Brian's mom's place in Columbus.
She has a fucking bed and breakfast and turn it into desk.
Quad studios turned it into the desk while compound.
You're going to fucking buy.
What are you going to do with Brian's mom?
We're going to get rid of her or the streets.
No,
she's got two houses and one of them,
she owns a bed and breakfast on a giant piece of land where we can hunt deer.
Dude,
I like it.
How many acres did you talk to?
Mom,
I haven't,
but I will.
It's a lot more than 20 acres.
You saw just the driveway.
Yeah.
Looks Great.
We need a few hundred acres.
We need it.
Ted Nugent style high fence keeps fucking Buffalo Rockland road.
I found a place online.
Some guy sent me this on Twitter where you can uh,
buy houses that are built on top of old missile silos.
There's a bunch of them.
Let's get one of those brother.
That's where they used to manufacture the LSD on the in a fucking,
yes.
That's,
that.
Was that a,
there was the a one that,
um,
what's his face?
Hamilton.
Morris.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Silo homes,
man.
There's a lot of those.
These are,
these are incredible.
They uh,
there's like several homes for sale that are built.
Like if you go to silo home.com,
you can check these out.
It sounds like the ultimate apocalyptic scenarios.
One of them has a fucking runway for a plane and like,
uh,
this rustic looking log house that's built over this several floor missile silo
that's converted into this crazy like storage compound.
Fucking fascinating shit.
Folks.
Prepare for the apocalypse.
It is coming.
Headache,
they snap it.
You know,
it already came to New York and New Jersey and all her brothers and sisters out
there on the beach in Jersey that lost your houses.
Mad,
love and respect to you and all the people in Long Island that lost it places
we,
we feel for you that fucking hurricanes,
a content,
a half and a,
it may be just the beginning of more crazy storms.
You've got to keep moving folks.
You can't stay in places that are getting ravaged by nature.
There's places on earth right now.
We can't live.
You can't live with their volcanoes.
You can't live in Antarctica.
You can't live in the fucking North Pole.
We got to keep moving.
Okay?
And that's one more aspect of our world where we have to understand that this is
really truly a global community and we can't live in the places that suck.
And we gotta be able to not be fucking territorial in except people into new
spots,
Mexico,
whatever.
And make love,
make love and let just flow from your penis is friends blasted and uh,
and make people if you can,
and raise them correctly and be nice.
All the folks around you gets up.
Love bombs.
Yeah.
The hand jobs.
Don't put those off just in,
don't,
yeah.
Give happiness.
Yes.
Brandon was scanned everything with handjobs jobs.
What are some girls?
Don't do that one when,
when it's time.
Okay.
Wow.
I don't know what you're saying.
Hey,
sound on the mouth.
If someone has a repulsive penis,
no one wants to suck.
It's beautiful.
It's like a route,
like the route of a fucking Rutabaga.
What's a Rutabaga?
Listen,
Dario,
it's an oak tree.
No,
I'm penis model.
I use my penis for condom models.
Sweet.
All right folks.
That is the end of this week's podcasts.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com for sponsoring our podcasts and on it is now going
to sponsor all of the desk squad podcasts,
including the Duncan Trussell family hour.
You can get on.
Uh,
where's my you on stitcher or you on Stitcher,
stitcher,
powerful stitcher.
Um,
we're,
we're up for some stitcher awards with,
by the way,
I don't give a fuck if we win or not because I'm not really an awards guy.
I think the awards for artist silly,
but if you give me an I'll accept it.
Uh,
we're a fucking chose over on at.com.
Use the code name,
Rogan,
uh,
save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Next week we have Phillip Copans,
um,
uh,
lost civilizations expert on Monday.
Brian Callan is on Tuesday at Peter Duesberg on Wednesday.
He is the a biologist from the University of California Berkeley that does not
believe that HIV causes AIDS.
Uh,
we've got a lot of cool shit coming on folks.
A Lot,
a lot of craziness.
You fucking dirty freaks and uh,
and that's it.
And by the way,
the new studio should be any week now.
It's almost done.
That's what we're setting up some things on next Wednesday and we may very well
start broadcasting live,
um,
in the month of November.
That's what it looks like.
Yeah,
it's going to be sick.
All right.
You fucks.
We love you.
We love the shit out of you and you are us and we are you one love how to keep
it going.
Locked the shit
[inaudible].